hey guys and welcome to a brand new
tutorial series on neural networks with
Python and tensorflow 2.0 now tensorflow
2.0 is the brand-new version of
tensorflow still actually in the alpha
stages right now but it should be
released within the next few weeks but
because it's an alpha tensorflow has
been kind enough to release us that
alpha version so that's what we're gonna
be working with in this tutorial series
and this will work for all future
versions of tensorflow
2.0 so don't be worried about that now
before I get too far into this first
video I just want to quickly give you an
overview of exactly what I'm gonna be
doing throughout this series so you guys
have an idea of what to expect and what
you're going to learn now the beginning
videos and especially this one are going
to be dedicated to understanding how a
neural network works and I think this is
absolutely fundamental and you have to
have some kind of basis on the math
behind a neural network before you're
really able to actually properly
implement one now tensorflow does a
really nice job of making it super easy
to implement neural networks and use
them but to actually have a successful
and complex neural network you have to
understand how they work on the lower
level so that's what we're gonna be
doing for the first few videos after
that what we'll do is we'll start
designing our own neural networks that
can solve the very basic Emnes data sets
that tensorflow provides to us now these
are pretty straightforward and pretty
simple but they give us a really good
building block on understanding how the
architecture of a neural network works
what are some of the different
activation functions how you can connect
layers and all of that which will
transition us nicely into creating our
own neural networks using our own data
for something like playing a game now
personally I'm really interested with
neural networks playing games and I'm
sure a lot of you are as well and that's
what I'm gonna be aiming to do near the
end of the series on kind of our larger
project I'll be designing a neural
network and tweaking it so they can play
a very basic game that I've personally
designed in Python with PI game now with
that being said that's kind of eight
four we're gonna be doing in this series
I may continue this on future in later
videos and do like very specific neural
network series maybe a chatbot or
something like that but I need you guys
to let me know what you'd like to see in
the comments down below
with that being said if you're excited
about the series
make sure you drop a like on this video
and subscribe to the channel to be
notified when I post the new videos and
with that being said let's get into this
first video on how a neural network
works and what a neural network is so
let's start talking about what a neural
network is and how they work now when
you hear neural network you usually
think of neurons
now neurons are what compose our brain
and I believe don't quote me on this we
have billions of them in our body or in
our brain now the way that neurons work
on a very simple and high level is you
have a bunch of them that are connected
in some kind of way so let's say these
are four neurons and they're connected
in some kind of pattern now in this case
our pattern is completely like like
random we're just arbitrary we're just
picking a connection but this is the way
that they're connected
okay now neurons can either fire or not
fire so you need to be on or off just
like a 1 or 0 ok so let's say that for
some reason this neuron decides to fire
maybe you touch something maybe you
smelt something something fires in your
brain and this neuron decides to fire
now it's connected to in this case all
of the other neurons so what it will do
is it will look at its other neurons and
the connection and it will possibly
cause it's connected neurons to fire or
to not fire so in this case let's say
maybe did what this one firing causes
this connected neuron to fire this one
to fire and maybe this one was already
firing and now it's decided it turned it
off or something like that ok so that's
what happened now when this neuron fires
well it's connected to this neuron and
it's connected to this nerve well it's
already got that connection but let's
say that maybe when this one fires it
causes this one to on fire because it
was just fired something like that right
and then this one now that it's off it
causes this one to fire back up and then
it goes it's just a chain of firing and
unfired
and that's just kind of how it works
right firing an unfired now that's as
far as i'm going to go into explaining
neurons but this kind of gives us a
little bit of a basis for a neural
network now a neural network essentially
is a connected layer of neurons or
connected layers so multiple of neurons
so in this case let's say that we have a
first layer we're going to call this our
input
that has four gnomes and we have one
more layer that only contains one nur
now these neurons are connected now in
our neural network we can have our
connections happening in different ways
we can have each woody Coates neuron
connected to each other neurons so from
layer to layer or we can have like some
connected to others some not connected
so I'm connected multiple times it
really depends on the type of neural
network we're doing now in most cases
what we do is we have what's called a
fully connected neural network which
means that each neuron in one layer is
connected to each neuron in the next
layer exactly one time so if I were to
add another neuron here then what would
happen is each of these neurons would
also connect to this neuron one time so
we would have a total of eight
connections because four times two is
eight right and that's how that would
work now for simplicity sake we're just
gonna use one neuron in the next layer
just to make things a little bit easier
to understand now all of these
connections have what is known as a
weight now this is in a neural network
specifically okay so we're gonna say
this is known as weight one this is
known as way - this is weight three and
this is weight 4 and again just to rehab
size this is known as our input layer
because it is the first layer in our
connected layers of neurons okay and
going with that the last layer in our
connected layer of neurons is known as
our output layer now these are the only
two layers that we really concern
ourselves with when we look and use a
neural network now obviously when we
create them we have to determine what
layers we're gonna have in the
connection type but when we're actually
using the neural network to make
predictions or to Train it
we are only concerning ourselves with
the input layer and the output layer now
what does this do and how do these
neural networks work well essentially
given some kind of input we want to do
something with it and get some kind of
output right in most instances that's
what you want input results in the
output in this case we have four inputs
and we have
output but we could have a case where we
have four inputs and we have 25 outputs
right it really depends on the kind of
problem we're trying to solve so this is
a very simple example but what I'm going
to do is show you how we would or how a
neuron that work would work to train a
very basic snaking so let's look at a
very basic snake game so let's say this
is our snake okay and this is his head
actually yeah let's say this is his head
but like this is what the position the
snake looks like where this is the tail
okay we'll circle the tail now what I
want to do is I want to train a neural
network that will allow this snake to
stay alive so essentially its output
will be what direction to go in or like
to follow a certain direction or not
okay essentially just keep this snake a
lot that's what I want it to do now how
am I gonna do this well the first step
is to decide what our input is gonna be
and then to decide what our output is
going to be so in this case I think a
clever input is gonna be do we have
something in front of the snake do we
have something to the left of the snake
and do we have something to the right of
the snake because in this case all
that's here is just the snake and he
just needs to be able to survive so what
we'll do is we'll say okay is there
something to the left yes no something
in front yes no so 0 1 something to the
right yes no and then our last input
will be a recommended direction for the
snake to go in so the recommended
direction could be anything so in this
case maybe we'll say the recommended
direction is left and what our output
will be is whether or not to follow that
recommended direction or not or to try
to do a different recommendation
essentially or go to a different
direction so let's do one case on how we
would expect this neural network to
perform without rain like once it's
trained right based on some given input
so let's say there's not something to
the left so we're gonna put a 0 here
because this one will represent if
there's anything to the left the next
one will be front so we'll say well
there's nothing in front the next one
will be to the right so we'll say right
and we'll say yes there is something to
the right of the snake and our
recommended direction what can be
anything we'd like so in this case we
say the recommended direction is left
and we'll way we'll do the recommended
direction is negative
1:01 where negative one is left zero is
in front and one is to the right okay so
we'll say in this case our recommended
direction is negative one and we'll just
denote this by direction now our output
in this instance should either be a zero
or one representing do we follow the
recommended direction or do we not so
let's see in this case following the
recommended direction would keep our
snake alive
so we'll say 1 yes we will follow the
recommended direction that is acceptable
that is fine we're gonna stay alive when
we do that now let's see what happens
when we change the recommended direction
to be right so let's say that we say 1
as a recommended direction again this is
during here then what should our output
be well if we decide to go right we're
gonna crash into our tail which means
that we should not follow that direction
so our output should be 0 so I hope
you're understanding how we would expect
this neural network to perform all right
so now how do we actually design this
neural network how do we get this work
how do we train this right well that is
a very good question and that is what
I'm gonna talk about now so let me
actually just erase some of this stuff
so we have a little bit more room to
work with some math stuff right here but
right now what we start by doing is we
start by designing what's known as the
architecture of our neural network so
we've already done this we have the
input and we have the output now each of
our inputs is connected to our outputs
and each of these connections has what's
known as a weight now another thing that
we have is each of our input neurons has
a value right we had in this case we
either had 0 or we had 1 now these
values can be different right these
values can either be decimal values or
they can be like between 0 and 100 they
don't have to be just between 0 and 1
but the point is that we have some kind
of value right so what we're gonna do in
this output layer to determine what way
we should go is essentially we are going
to take the weighted sum of the values
multiplied by the weights I'm gonna talk
about how this works more in depth in a
second but just just follow me now so
what this symbol means is take the sum
and what we do is I'm gonna say in this
case I which is gonna be our variable
and
talk about how this kind of thing works
in a second we'll say I equals one and
I'm going to say we'll take the weighted
sum of in this case value I multiplied
by weight I so what this means
essentially is we're going to start at I
equals 1 we're gonna use I as our
variable for looping and we're gonna say
in this case we're gonna do B 1 times V
I VI times W I and then we're gonna add
all this so what this will return to us
actually will be V 1 W 1 plus V 2 W 2
plus V 3 w 3 plus V 4 w 4 and this will
be our output that's that's what our
output layer is going to have as a value
now this doesn't really make much sense
right now right like why why we doing
this weights what is this multiplication
we'll just follow with me for one second
so this is what our output layer is
going to do now there's one thing that
we have to add to this as well and this
is what is known as our biases okay so
what we're gonna do is we're going to
take this weighted sum but we're also
going to have some kind of bias on each
of these weights okay
and what this bias is known as it's
denoted by C typically but essentially
it is some value that we just
automatically add or subtract it's a
constant value for each of these weights
so we're gonna say all of these these
connections have weight but they also
have a bias so we're gonna have B 1 B 2
B 3 and B 4 is what we'll call it B
instead of C so what I'll do here is
what I'm also going to do is I'm also
gonna add these biases in when I do
these weights so we're going to say B I
as well so now what we'll have is we'll
have at the end here plus bi or plus B 1
plus B 2 plus B 3 + B 4 now again I know
you guys like what the heck am I doing
with this this makes no sense it's about
to make sense in one second so now what
we need to do is we need to train the
network so we've understood now this is
essentially what this output layers
doing we're taking all of these weights
and these values we're multiplying them
together and we're adding them and we're
taking what's known as the weighted sum
okay
but how do we like what are these values
how do we get these values and how is
this gonna give us a valid output well
what we're going to do is we're gonna
train the network on a ton of different
information so let's say we play 1,000
games of snake and we get all of the
different inputs and all the different
outputs so what we'll do is we'll
randomly decide like a recommended
direction and we'll just take the state
of the snake which will be either
there's something left to the right
we're in front of it and then we'll take
the output which will be like did the
snake survive or did the snake not
survive so well what we'll do is we'll
train the network using that information
so we'll generate all of this different
information and then train the network
and what the network will do is it will
look at all of this information and it
will start adjusting these biases and
these weights to properly get a correct
output because what we'll do is we'll
give it all this input right so let's
say we give it the input again of zero
one zero and maybe one like this random
input and let's say the output for this
case is what do you call it so one is go
to the right the output is one which is
correct well what the network could do
is say okay I got that correct so what
I'm gonna do is I'm not gonna bother
adjusting the network because this fine
so I don't have to change any of these
biases I don't have to change any of
these weights everything is working fine
but let's say that we get the answer
wrong so maybe the output was zero but
the answer should have been one because
we know the answer obviously because
we've generated all the input and the
output so now what the network will do
is it will start adjusting these weights
and adjusting these biases they'll say
all right so I got this one wrong and
I've gotten like five or six wrong
before and this is what was familiar
when I got something wrong so let's add
one to this bias or let's multiply this
weight by two and what it will do is
it'll start adjusting these weights and
these biases so that it gets more things
correct so obviously that's why neural
networks typically take a massive amount
of information to Train because what you
do is you pass it all of this
information and then it keeps going
through the network and at the beginning
it sucks right because it doesn't this
network just starts with random weights
and random biases but as it goes through
and it learns it says okay
well I got this one correct so let's
leave the weights and the bias is the
same but let's remember that this is
what the way in the bias was when this
was correct and then maybe he gets
something wrong and it says okay so
let's adjust bias one a little bit
let's adjust weight one let's mess with
these and then let's try another example
and then it says okay I got this example
right maybe we're moving in the right
direction maybe you will adjust another
way maybe we'll adjust another bias and
that's eventually your goal is that you
get to a point where your network is
very accurate because you've given it a
ton of data and it's adjusted the
weights and the biases correctly so that
this kind of formula here of this
weighted average will just always give
you the correct answer or has a very
high accuracy or high chance of giving
you the correct answer so I hope that
kind of makes sense I'm definitely over
simplifying things in how the adjustment
of these weights and these biases work
but it's not crazy important and we're
not going to be doing any of the
adjustment ourselves we're we are just
gonna be kind of tweaking a few things
with the network so as long as you
understand that when you feed
information what happens is it checks
whether the network got it correct or it
got it incorrect and then it adjusts the
network accordingly and that is how the
learning process works for a neural
network alright so now it's time to
discuss a little bit about activation
functions so right now what I've
actually just described to you is a very
advanced technique of linear regression
so essentially I was saying we are
adjusting weights we're adjusting biases
and essentially we are creating a
function that given the inputs of like X
Y Z W or like left front right we are
giving some kind of output but all we've
been doing to do that essentially is
just adjusting a linear function because
our degree is only 1 right we have
weights of degree one multiplying by
values of degree one and we're adding
some kind of bias and that kind of
reminds you of the form MX plus B we're
literally just adding a bunch of MX plus
B is together which gives us like a
fairly complex linear function but this
is really not a great way to do things
because it limits the degree of
complexity that our network can actually
have to be linear and that's not what we
want so now we have to talk about
activation functions
so if you understand everything that
I've talked about so far you're doing
amazing this is great you understand
that essentially the way that the
network works is you feed information in
and it adjusts these weights and biases
there's a specific way it does that
which we'll talk about later and then
you get some kind of output and based on
that output you're trying to adjust the
weights and biases and and all that
right so now what we need to do is talk
about activation functions and what an
activation function does is it's
essentially a nonlinear function that
will allow you to add a degree of
complexity to your network so that you
can have more of a function that's like
this as opposed to a function that is a
straight line so an example of an
activation function is something like a
sigmoid function now a sigmoid function
what it does is it'll map any value you
give it in between the value of negative
1 and 1
so for example when we create this
Network our output might be like the
number 7 now this number 7 well it is
closer to 1 that is to 0 so we might
deem that a correct answer or we might
say that this is actually way off
because it's way above 1 right but what
we want to do essentially is in our
output layer we only want our values to
be within a certain range we want them
to be in this case between 0 and 1 or
maybe we want them to be between
negative 1 and 1 I'm saying like how
close we are to 0 making that decision
how close we are to 1 something like
that right so what the sigmoid
activation function does it's a
nonlinear function and it takes any
value and essentially the closer that
value is to infinity the closer the
output is to 1 and the closer that value
is to negative infinity the closer that
output is to negative 1 so what it does
is it adds a degree of complexity to our
network now if you don't if you're not a
high level like math student or you only
know like very basic high school math
this might not really make sense to you
but essentially the degree of something
right is honestly how complex you can
get if you have like a degree 9 function
then what you could do is you can have
some crazy kind of curve and stuff going
on especially in multiple dimensions
that will just make things like much
more complex
so for example if you have like a degree
nine function you can have curves that
are going like like this like all around
here that are mapping your different
values and if you only have a linear
function well you can only have a
straight line which limits your degree
of complexity by a significant amount
now what these activation functions also
do is they shrink down your data so that
it is not as large so for example right
like say we're looking with data that is
like hundreds of thousands of like
characters long or digits we'd want to
shrink that into like normalize that
data so that it's easier to actually
work with so let me give you a more
practical example of how to use the
activation function I talked about what
sigmoid does what we would do is we
would take this weighted sum so we did
the sum of WI bi plus bi right and we
would apply an activation function to
this so we'd say maybe our activation
function is f of X and we would say F of
this and this gives us some value which
is now gonna be our output neuron and
the reason we do that again is so that
when we are adjusting our weights and
biases and we add that activation
function in now we can have a way more
complex function as opposed to just
having the kind of linear regression
straight line which is what we've I've
talked about in my other machine
learning courses so if this is kind of
going a little bit over your head
it may be my lack of explaining it I'd
love to hear in the comments below how
you think this explanation but
essentially that's what the activation
function does now another activation
function that is very popular and is
actually used way more than sigmoid
nowadays is known as rectified linear
unit and what this does is it having
taught in red actually so if we can see
it better is it takes all of the values
that are negative and automatically puts
them to zero and takes all of the values
that are positive and just makes them
more positive essentially or like to
some level positive right
and what this again is gonna do is it's
a nonlinear function so it's going to
enhance the complexity of our model and
just make our data points in between the
range zero and positive infinity which
is better than having between negative
infinity and positive infinity for when
were calculating air all right
last thing to talk about for neural
networks in this video I'm trying to
kind of get everything like briefly into
one long video is a loss function so
this is again gonna help us understand
how these weights and these biases are
actually adjusted so we know that
they're adjusted and we know that what
we do is we look at the output and we
compare it to what the output should be
from our test data and then we say okay
well it's adjust the weights and the
biases accordingly but how do we adjust
that and how do we know how far off we
are how much to tune by if an adjustment
even needs to be made well we use what's
known as a loss function so a loss
function essentially is a way of
calculating error now there's a ton of
different loss loss functions some of
them are like mean squared error that's
the name of one of them I think one is
like I can't even remember the name of
this one but there's there's a bunch of
very popular ones if you know some leave
them in the comments love to hear all
the different ones but anyways what the
loss function will do is tell you how
wrong your answer is because like let's
think about this right if you get an
answer of let's say maybe our output is
like zero point seven nine and the
actual answer was one well that's pretty
close
like that's pretty close to one but
right now all we're gonna get is the
fact that we were zero point two one off
okay so zero point two went off so
adjust the weights a certain degree
based on zero point two one but the
thing is what if we get like zero point
eight five
well is this like this is significantly
better than zero point seven nine but
this is only gonna say that we were
better by what is this is zero point one
five so we're still gonna do significant
amount of justing to the weights and the
biases so what we need to do is need to
apply a loss function to this that will
give us a better kind of degree of like
how wrong or how right we were now these
loss functions are again not linear loss
functions which means that we're gonna
add a higher degree of complexity to our
model which will allow us to create way
more complex models and neural networks
that can solve better problems I don't
really want to talk about loss functions
too much because I'm definitely no
expert on how they work but essentially
what you do is you're comparing the
output to the
what the output should be so like
whatever the model generated based what
it should be and then you're gonna get
some value and based on that value you
are going to adjust the biases and the
weights accordingly the reason we use go
loss function again is because we want a
higher degree of complexity they're
nonlinear and you know if you get zero
if you're 99% like say your point one
away from the correct answer we probably
want to adjust the weights very very
little but if you're like way off the
answer your two whole points may be our
answer is negative one we want it to be
one
well we want to adjust the model like
crazy right because that model was
horribly wrong it wasn't even close so
we would adjust it way more than just
like two points of adjustment right we
adjust it based on whatever that loss
function gave to us so anyways this has
kind of been my explanation of a neural
network I want to Barrett I want to stay
right here for everyone that I am no pro
on neural networks this is my
understanding there might be some stuff
that's a little bit flawed or some areas
that I skipped over and quickly actually
because I know some people probably
gonna say this when you're creating
neural networks as well you have another
thing that is called hidden layers so
right now we've only been using two
layers but in most neural networks what
you have is a ton of different input
neurons that connect to what's known as
a hidden layer or multiple hidden layers
of neurons so let's say we have like an
architecture maybe that looks something
like this so all these connections and
then these ones connect to this and what
this allows you to do is have way more
complex models that can solve way more
difficult problems because you can
generate different combinations of
inputs and he didn't what is known as
hidden layered neurons to solve your
problem and have more weights and more
biases to adjust which means you can on
average be more accurate to produce
certain models so you can have crazy
neural networks that look something like
this but with way more neurons and way
more layers and all this kind of stuff I
just wanted to show a very basic network
today because I didn't want to go in and
talk about like a ton of stuff
especially cuz I know a lot of people
that watch my videos are not pro math
guys are just trying to get a basic
understanding and be able to implement
some of this stuff
now in today's video what we're gonna be
doing is actually getting our hands
dirty and working with a bit of code and
loading in our first data set so we're
not actually gonna do anything with the
model right now we're gonna do that in
the next video
this video is gonna be dedicated to
understanding data the importance of
data how we can scale that data look at
it and understand how that's going to
affect our model when training the most
important part of machine learning at
least in my opinion is the data and it's
also one of the hardest things to
actually get done correctly training the
model and testing the model and using it
is actually very easy and you guys will
see that as we go through but getting
the right information to our model and
having it in the correct form is
something that is way more challenging
than it may seem with these initial data
sets that we're gonna work with things
are gonna be very easy because the
datasets are gonna be given to us but
when we move on into future videos -
using our own data we're gonna have to
pre-process it we're gonna have to put
it in its correct form we're gonna have
to send it into an array I'm gonna have
to make sure that the data makes sense
so we're not adding things that
shouldn't be there or we're not omitting
things that need to be there so anyways
I'm just gonna quickly say here that I
am kind of working off of this
tensorflow 2.0 tutorial that is on
tensor flows website now I'm kind of
gonna stray from it quite a bit to be
honest but I'm just using the data sets
that they have and a little bit of the
code that they have here because it's a
very nice introduction to machine
learning and neural networks but there's
a lot of stuff in here that they don't
talk about and it's not very in-depth so
that's what I'm can I get to be adding
and the reason why maybe you'd want to
watch my version of this as opposed to
just reading this off the website
because if you have no experience with
neural networks it is kind of confusing
some of the stuff they do here and they
don't really talk about why they use
certain things or whatnot so anyways the
data set we're gonna be working with
today is known as the fashion m-miss
data set so you may have heard of the
old does so which is image image
classification but it was like digits so
like you had digits from 0 to 9 and the
neural network about classified digits
this one's very similar principle except
we're gonna be doing it with like
t-shirts and pants and
what-do-you-call-it sandals and all that
so these are kind of some examples what
the images look like and we'll be
showing them as well in in the code so
that's enough about it I felt like I
should tell you guys that the first
thing that we
doing before we can actually start
working with tensorflow is we obviously
need to install it now actually maybe
I'll grab the install command here so
I'll have to copy it but this is the
install command for tensorflow 2.0 so
I'm just gonna copy it here link will be
in the description as well as on my
website and you can see pink pip install
- q tensorflow equals equals 2.0 point o
- alpha zero now I already have this
installed but I'm gonna go ahead and hit
enter anyways in the - Q I believe just
means don't give any output when you're
installing so if this runs and you don't
see any output whatsoever then you have
successfully installed tensorflow 2.0
now I ran into an issue where I couldn't
install it because I had a previous
version of numpy installed in my system
so if for some reason this doesn't work
and there's something with numpy I would
just PIP uninstall numpy and reinstall
so do pip uninstall numpy like that I'm
always not gonna run that but if you did
that and then you tried to reinstall
town photo 2.0 that should work for you
and it should actually install its own
version of the most updated version of
numpy now another thing we're going to
install here is going to be matplotlib
now matplotlib is a nice library for
just graphing and showing images and
different information that we'll use a
lot through this series so let's install
that I already have it installed but go
ahead and do that and then finally we
will install pandas which we may be
using in later videos in the series so I
figured we might as well install it now
so pip install pandas and once you've
done that you should be ready to
actually go here and start getting our
data loaded in and looking at the data
so I'm just gonna be working on sub line
text and executing my Python files from
the command line just because this is
something that will work for everyone no
matter what but feel free to work in
ideally feel for you to work in PI tram
as long as you understand how to set up
your environment so that you have the
necessary packages like tensorflow and
all that then you should be good to go
so let's start by importing tensorflow
so import tensorflow as TF like that I
don't know why it always short forms
when I try to do this but anyways we're
gonna import or actually sorry from
tensorflow
will import care as now Kara's is an API
for tensorflow which essentially
allows us to write less code it does a
lot of stuff for us like you'll see when
we set up the model we use Kara's and
it'll be really nice and simple and just
like a high-level API that's the way
that they describe it that makes things
a lot easier for people like us that
aren't going to be defining our own
tensors and writing our own code from
scratch essentially now another thing we
need to import is numpy so we're going
to say import if I could get this here
import numpy as NP and finally we will
import matplotlib so Matt plot lib in
this case thought pipe lot as P ot and
this again is just going to allow us to
graph some things here all right so now
what we're gonna do is we're actually
gonna get our data set loaded in so the
way that we can load in our data set is
using Chara's so to do this I'm just
gonna say data equals in this case
Kara's dot data sets dot fashion
underscore m-miss and this is just the
name of the data set there's a bunch of
other data sets inside of Kara's that we
will be using in the future now whenever
we have data it's very important that we
split our data into testing and training
data now you may have heard this you
talked about this in the previous
machine learning tutorials I did but
essentially what you want to do with any
kind of machine learning algorithm
especially a neural network is you don't
want to pass all of your data into the
network when you train it you want to
pass about 90 80 percent of your data to
the network to train it and then you
want to test the network for accuracy
and making sure that it works properly
on the rest of your data that it hasn't
seen yet
now the reason you'd want to do this and
a lot of people would say why don't I
just give all my dad's the network and
it'd make it better not necessarily and
that's because if you test your data on
if you test your network on data it's
already seen then you can't be sure that
it's not just simply memorizing the data
it's seen right for example if you show
me five images and then like you tell me
the classes of all of them and then you
show me that the same image again you
say what's the class and I get it right
well did I get it right because I
figured out how to analyze the images
properly or because I'd already seen it
and I knew what it was right I just
memorized what it was so that's
something we wanted
try to avoid with our models so whenever
we have our data we're gonna split it up
into testing and training data and
that's what we're gonna do right here so
to do this I'm going to say train in
this case train underscore images and
trained under store the labels combi in
this case test underscore images
call-out test underscore in labels and
then we say this is equal to data don't
get underscore data so not get load
unders we're done now the reason we can
do this is just because this load data
method is gonna return information in a
way where we can kind of split it up
like this in most cases when you're
writing your own models for your own
data you're gonna have to write your own
arrays and for loops and load and data
and do all this fancy stuff but Chara's
makes it nice and easy for us just by
allowing us to write this line here
which will get us our training and
testing data in the for kind of
variables that we need so quickly let me
talk about what labels are now so for
this specific data set there are ten
labels and that means each image that we
have will have a specific label assigned
to it now if I actually I'll show you by
just printing out if I print for example
train underscore labels and let's just
print like these zero if I guess the
first training label so let me just run
this file so python tutorial 1 you can
see that we simply get the number 9 now
this is just what is represented like
the label representation so obviously
it's not giving us a string but let's
say if I pick for example 6 and I hit
enter here you can see that the label is
7 so the labels are between 0 & 9 so 10
labels in total another thing is that's
not very useful to us because we don't
really know what label 0 is will label 9
is so what I'm gonna do is create a list
that will actually define what those
labels are so I'm gonna have to copy it
from here because I actually don't
remember the labels but you can see it
says here what they are so for example
the label 0 is a t-shirt label 1 is a
trouser 9 is an ankle boot and you can
see what they all are
so we just need to define exactly this
list here so class names so that we can
simply take whatever value is returned
to us from the model of what label it
thinks it is and then just throw that as
an index to this list so we
get what label dis all right sweet so
that is how we're getting the data now
so now I want to show you what some of
these images look like and talk about
the architecture of the neural network
we might use in the next video
so I'm gonna use PI plot just to show
you some of these images and explain
kind of the input and the output and all
that so if I if you want to show an
image using matplotlib you can do this
by just doing PLT imshow and then in
here simply putting the image so for
example if i do train not labels images
and let's say we do the seventh image
and then I do PLT dot show if I run this
now you guys will see what this image is
so let's run this and you can see that
we get this is actually I believe like a
pullover or a hoodie now I know it looks
weird and you've got all this like green
and purple that's just because of the
way that kind of matplotlib shows these
images if you want to see it properly
what you do is I believe you do see map
equals in this case
PLT dot see it I think it's like cm de
binary or something I gotta have a look
here because I forget yeah CMB binary so
if we do this and now we decide to
display the image it should look a
little bit better let's see here
and there you go we can see now we're
actually getting this like black and
white kind of image now this is great
and all but let me show you actually
what our image looks like so like how
was I just able to show like how was I
just able to do this image well the
reason I'm able to do that is because
all of our images are actually a raise
of 28 by 28 pixels so let me print one
out for you here so if I do train
underscore images let's do seven the
same example here and print that to the
screen I'll show you what the data
actually looks like give it a second and
there we go so you can see this is
obviously what our data looks like it's
just a bunch of lists
so one list for each row and it just has
pixel values and these pixel values are
simply representative of I believe like
how much I don't actually know the scale
that they're on but I think it's like an
RGB value but in greyscale right so for
example we have like 0 to 255 where 255
is black and 0 is white and I'm pretty
sure that's how getting
the information in someone can correct
me if I'm wrong but I'm almost certain
that that's how this actually works so
this is gray Knoll but this is these are
large numbers and remember I was saying
before in the previous video that's
typically a good idea to shrink our data
down so that it's with it within a
certain range that is a bit smaller so
in this case what I'm actually going to
do is I'm gonna modify this information
a little bit so that we only have each
value out of one so we instead of having
no 255 we have it out of one so the way
to do that is to divide every single
pixel value by 255 now because these
trained images are actually stored in
what's known as a numpy array we can
simply just divide it by 255 to achieve
that so we'll say train images equals
train images / 255 and we'll do the same
thing here with our test images as well
now obviously we don't have to modify
the labels as well also because they're
just between 0 & 9 and that's how the
labels work but for our images we're
going to divide those values so that
it's a bit nicer so now let me show you
what it looks like so if I go python
tutorial 1 del pine and now you can see
that we're getting these decimal values
and that our shirt looks well the same
but exactly like we've just shrunk down
our data so it's gonna be easier to work
with in the future with our model now
that's about it I think that I'm gonna
show you guys in terms of this data now
we have our data loaded in and we're
pretty much ready to go in terms of
making a model now if you have any
questions about the data please don't
hesitate to leave a comment down below
but essentially again the way it works
is we're gonna have 28 by 28 pixel
images and they're gonna come in as an
array just as I've showed you here so
these are all the values that we're
gonna have we're gonna pass that to our
model and then our model is gonna spit
out what class it thinks it is and those
classes are going to be between 0 & 9
obviously 0 is going to represent a
t-shirt where 9 is going to represent
ankle boots and we will deal with that
all in the next video
now in today's video we're actually
gonna be working with the neural network
so we're gonna be setting up a model
we're gonna be training that model we're
gonna be testing that model to see how
well it performed we will also use it to
predict on individual images and all of
that fun stuff so without further ado
let's get started now the first thing
that I want to do before we really get
into actually writing any code is talk
about the architecture of the neural
network we're going to create now I
always found in tutorials that I watch
they never really explained exactly what
the layers were doing what they looked
like and why we chose such layers and
that's what I'm hoping to give to you
guys right now so if you remember before
we know now that our images they come in
essentially as like 28 by 28 pixels and
the way that we have them is we have an
array and we have another array inside
it's like a two dimensional array and
house pixel values so maybe it's like
0.1 0.3 which is the grayscale value and
this goes and there's times 28 and each
row of these these pixels now there's 28
rows obviously because well 28 by 28
pixels so in here again we have the same
thing more pixel values and we go down
28 times right and that's what we have
and that's what our array looks like now
that's what our input data is that's
fine but this isn't really gonna work
well for our neural network what are we
gonna do we're gonna have one neuron and
we're just gonna pass this whole thing
to it I don't think so that's not gonna
work very well so what we need to
actually do before we can even like
start talking about the neural network
is figure out a way that we can change
this information into a way that we can
give it to the neural network so what
I'm actually gonna do and what I mean
most people do is they they do what's
called flatten the data so actually
maybe we'll go I can't even go back once
I clear it but flattening the data
essentially is taking any like interior
list so let's say we have like lists
like this and just like squishing them
all together so rather than so let's say
this is like 1 2 3 if we were to flatten
this what we would do is while we remove
all of these interior arrays or lists or
whatever it is so we would just end up
getting data it looks like 1 2 3 and
this actually turns out to work just
fine for us so in this instance we only
had like 1
in each array but when we're dealing
with 28 elements in each sorry list
listen array they're interchangeable
just in case I keep saying those what
will essentially have is will flatten
the data so we get a list of length 784
and I believe that is because well I
mean I know this house because 28 times
28 equals 784 so when we flatten that
data so 28 rows of 28 pixels then we end
up getting 784 pixels just one after
each other and that's what we're gonna
feed in as the input to our neural
network so that means that our initial
input layer is gonna look something like
this we're gonna have a bunch of neurons
and they're gonna go all the way down so
we're gonna have 784 neurons so let's
say this is 7 8 4 I know you could
probably hardly read that but you get
the point and this is our input layer
now before we even talk about any kind
of hidden layers let's talk about our
output layer so what is our output
well our output is gonna be a number
between 0 and 9 ideally that's what we
want so what we're actually gonna do for
our output layer is rather than just
having one neuron that we use kind of in
the last the two videos ago as an
example is we're actually gonna have 10
neurons each one representing one of
these different classes right so we have
0 to 9
so obviously 10 neurons or 10 classes so
let's have 10 neurons so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 now what's gonna happen with these
neurons is each one of them is going to
have a value and that value is gonna
represent how much the network thinks
that it is each neuron so for example
say we're classifying the image that
looks like a t-shirt or maybe like a
pair of pants so those are pretty easy
to draw so let's say this is the image
we're given a little pair of pants
what's gonna happen is let's say pants
is like this one like this is the one it
actually should be all of these will be
lit up a certain amount so essentially
maybe we'll say like we think it's 0.05
percent this we have like a degree of
certainty that it's 10 percent this one
and then it is like we think it's 75
percent pants so what we'll do when we
are looking at this output layer is
essentially we'll just find whatever
is the greatest so whatever probability
is the greatest and then say that's the
one that the network predicts is the
class of the given object right so when
we're training the network what we'll do
essentially is we'll say okay well we're
giving the pants so we know that this
one should be one right this should be a
hundred percent it should be one that's
what it should be and all these other
ones should be zero right because it
should be a zero percent chance it's
anything else because we know that it is
pants and then that work will look at
all this and adjust all the weights and
biases accordingly so that we get it so
that it lights this one up directly as
one at least that's our goal right so
once we do that so now we've talked with
the input layer and the output layer now
it's time to talk about our hidden
layers so we could technically train a
network that would just be two layers
right and we just have all these inputs
that go to some kind of outputs but that
wouldn't really do much for us because
essentially that would just mean we're
just gonna look at all the pixels and
based on that configuration of pixels
will point to you know these output
layers and that means we're only gonna
have which I know it sounds only 784
times 10 weights and biases so 784 times
10 which means that we're only gonna
have 7840 weights right weights and
biases things to address so what we're
actually gonna do is we're gonna add a
hidden layer inside of here now you can
kind of arbitrarily arbitrarily pick how
many neurons you're gonna have in your
hidden layer it's a good idea to kind of
go off based on percentages from your
input layer but what we're gonna have is
we're gonna have a hidden layer and in
this case this hidden layer is gonna
have a hundred and twenty eight neurons
so we'll say this is 128 and this is
known as our hidden layer so what will
happen now is we're gonna have our
inputs connecting to the hidden layer so
fully connected and then the hidden
layer will be connected to all of our
output neurons which will allow for much
more complexity of our network because
we're gonna have a ton more biases and a
ton more weights connecting to this
middle layer which maybe we'll be able
to figure out some patterns like maybe
to look for like a straight line that
looks like a pant sleeve it looks like
an arm sleeve maybe they'll look for
concentration of a certain area in the
picture right and not
we're hoping that our hidden lair will
maybe be able to do for us maybe pick on
pick up on some kind of patterns and
then maybe with these combination of
patterns we can pick out what specific
image it actually is now we don't really
know what the hidden network or hidden
layer is gonna do we just kind of have
some hopes for it and by picking 128
neurons we're saying okay we're going to
allow this hidden layer to kind of
figure its own way out and figure out
some way of analyzing this image and
then that's essentially what we're gonna
do so if you have any questions about
that please do not hesitate to ask but
the hidden layers are pretty arbitrary
sorry I just dropped my pen which means
that you know you can kind of experiment
with them kind of tweak with them
there's some that are known to be to do
well but typically when you're picking a
hidden layer you pick one and you
typically go at like maybe 15-20 percent
of the input size but again it really
depends on the application that you're
you're using so let's now actually just
start working with our data and creating
a model so if we want to create a model
the first thing that we need to do is
define the architecture or the layers
for a model and that's what we've just
done so I'm gonna type it out fairly
quickly here and again you guys will see
how this works so I'm gonna say model
equals in this case Kara's dot
sequential believe that's how you spell
it and then what we're gonna do is
inside here put a list and we're gonna
start defining our different layers so
we're gonna say care s dot layers and
our first layer is gonna be an input
layer but it's gonna be a flattened
input layer and the input underscore
shape is gonna be equal to 28 by 28 so
remember I talked about that initially
what we need to do is well we need to
flatten our data so that it is passable
to all those different neurons right so
essentially I gotta spell shape correct
shape correctly so essentially whenever
you're passing in information that's in
like a 2d or 3d array you need to
flatten that information so that you're
gonna be able to pass it to an
individual neuron as opposed to like
sending a whole list into one neuron
right now the next layer that we're
gonna have is going to be what's known
as a dense layer now a dense layer
essentially just means a fully connected
layer which means that what we've showed
so far which is only fully connected
neural
that works that's what we're gonna have
so each node or each neuron is connected
to every other neuron in the next
network so I'm gonna say layers dot
dense and in this case we're gonna give
it a hundred twenty-eight neurons that's
what we've talked about and we're gonna
set the activation function which we
talked about before as well to be
rectified linear unit now again this
activation function is somewhat
arbitrary in the fact that you can kick
different ones but rectifier linear unit
is a very fast activation function and
it works well for a variety of
applications and that is why we are
picking that now the next layer is gonna
be another dense layer which means
essentially another fully connected
layer sorry and we're gonna have ten
neurons and this is gonna be our output
layer and we're gonna have an activation
of softmax now what softmax does is
exactly what i explained when showing
you that kind of architecture picture it
will pick values for each neurons so
that all of those values add up to one
so essentially it is like the
probability of the network thinking it's
a certain value so it's like I believe
that it's 80 percent this two percent is
five percent this but all of the neurons
there those values will add up to one
and that's what the softmax softmax
function does so that actually means
that we can look at the last layer and
we can see the probability or what the
network thinks for each given class and
say maybe those are two classes that are
like 45% each we can maybe tweak the
output of the network to say like I am
Not sure
rather than predicting a specific value
right all right so now what we're gonna
do is we're gonna just set up some
parameters for our model so I'm gonna
say model compile and in this case we're
gonna use an optimizer of atom now I'm
not really going to talk about the
optimizer Adam is typically like pretty
standard especially for something like
this we're gonna use the loss function
of sparse and in this case underscore in
categorical believe I spelled that
correctly and then cross-entropy
now if you're interested in what these
do and how they work in terms like the
math kind of side of them just look them
up there's their very famous and popular
and there again are somewhat arbitrary
in terms of how you pick them now when I
do metrics I'm gonna say metrics
accuracy and again this is gonna define
what we're looking at when we're testing
the model in this case we care about the
accuracy or how low we can get this loss
function to be so yeah you guys can look
these up there's tons of different loss
functions some of them have different
applications and typically when you're
making a neural network your mess around
with different loss functions different
optimizers and in some cases different
metrics so now it is actually time to
train our model so to train our model
what we're gonna do is model dot fit and
when we fit it all we're gonna do is
give it our train images and our train
labels now we're gonna set the amount of
epochs so now it's time to talk about
epochs now epochs are actually fairly
straightforward you've probably heard of
the word epoch before but essentially it
means how many times the model is gonna
see this information so what an epoch is
gonna do is it's gonna kind of randomly
pick images and labels obviously
correspond to each other and it's gonna
feed that through the neural network so
how many epochs you decide is how many
times you're gonna see the same image so
the reason we do this is because the
order in which images come in will
influence how parameters and things are
tweaked with the network maybe seeing
like 10 images that are pants is gonna
tweak it differently than if it sees
like a few better pants and a few that
are a shirt and some that are sandals so
this is a very simple explanation of how
the epochs work but essentially it just
is giving the same images in a different
order and then maybe if it got one image
wrong it's gonna see it again and be
able to tweak and it's just a way to
increase hopefully the accuracy of our
model that being said giving more epochs
does not always necessarily increase the
accuracy of your model it's something
that you kind of have to play with and
anyone that does any machine learning or
neural networks will tell you that they
can't really like they don't know the
exact number epoch they have to play
with it and tweak it and see what gives
them the best accuracy so anyways now it
is time to actually well we can run this
but let's first get some kind of output
here so I'm gonna actually evaluate this
model directly after we run it so that
we can see how it works on our test data
so right now what this is doing is
actually just training the model on our
training data which means we're tweaked
all the weights and biases we're
applying all those activation functions
and we're defining like a mean function
for the model but if we actually want to
see how this works we can't really just
test it on the training images and
labels for the same reason I talked
about before so we have to test it on
the test images and the test labels and
essentially see how many it gets correct
so the way we do this is we're gonna say
test underscore loss test underscore AC
which stands for accuracy equals model
dot evaluate is that how you spell it
maybe and then we're gonna do test
images test underscore labels and I
believe that is the last parameter yes
it is so now if we want to see the
accuracy of our model we can simply
print out test underscore ACC and we'll
just say like tested ACC just so we know
because there is gonna be some other
metrics that are gonna be printing our
test when we run this all right so now
that we've done that let's actually run
our file and see how this works so this
is it this whole part here is all we
actually need to do to create a neural
network and do a model now actually let
me just quickly say that this Karis not
sequential what this does is it means a
like a sequence of layers so you're just
defining them in order where you say the
first layer obviously is gonna be your
input layer we're flattening the data
then we're adding two dense layers which
are fully connected to the input layer
as well and that's what our model looks
like and this is typically how you go
about creating a neural network all
right so let's run this now and see what
we get so this will take a second or two
to run just because obviously there is
what we have 60,000 images in this data
set so you know it's got a run through
them it's doing all the epochs and you
can see that we're getting metrics here
on our accuracy and our loss
now our test accuracy was 87 percent so
you can see that it's actually slightly
lower than what do you call it like the
accuracy here oh it's the exact same oh
it actually Auto tested on some data
sets but anyways so essentially that is
how this works you can see that the
first five epochs which are these ones
here
ran and they increase typically with
each epoch now again we could try like
10 bucks 20 bucks and see what it does
but there is a point where the more
epochs you do the actual like the less
reliable your model becomes and you can
see that our accuracy was started at
88.9 essentially and that was on like
that's what it said our model accuracy
was when we were training the model but
then once we actually tested it which of
these two lines here it was lower than
the be tested or like the trained
accuracy which shows you that you
obviously have to be testing on
different images because when we tested
it here it said well it was 89% but then
here we only got 87 percent right so
let's do a quick tweak here and just see
what we get maybe if we add like 10
epochs I don't think this will take a
crazy long amount of time so we'll run
this and see maybe if it makes a massive
difference or if it starts leveling out
or it starts going lower or whatnot
let me let this run here for a second
and obviously you can see the tweaked
accuracy as we continue to go I'm
interested to see here we're gonna
increase by much or if it's just kind of
gonna stay at the same level all right
so we're hitting about 90% and let's see
here 91 okay so we got up to 91% but you
can see that it was kind of diminishing
returns as soon as we ended up getting
to about 70 parks even yeah even like a
epochs after this we only increased by a
marginal amount and our accuracy on the
testing data was slightly better but
again for the amount of epochs five
extra epochs it did not give us a five
times better result right so it's
something you got to play with and see
now in today's video what we're gonna be
doing is just simply using our model to
actually predict information on specific
images and see how you actually use the
model I find a lot of tutorials series
don't show you how to actually
practically use the model but what's the
point of creating a model if you can't
use it now quickly before I get too far
into the video I would just like to show
you guys something that I'm super
excited to announce because I've been
waiting for them to come for a long time
and it is the official tech with Tim
mugs so you guys can see them here I
just wanted to quickly show them to you
guys if you'd like to support the
channel and get an awesome looking mug I
actually really like them then you guys
can purchase them just by I believe
underneath the video it shows like the
teespring link um but yeah they're
awesome they look really good and the
reason I've been holding out on showing
them to you guys is cuz I wanted to wait
till I recieved mine
to make sure that it was up to quality
and that it looked good enough to sell
to you guys essentially so if you'd like
to support the channel
um you can get one of those if not
that's fine but if you do decide to buy
one please send me like a DM on Twitter
Instagram or something and let me know
so I can say thank you to you guys so
anyways let's get into the video um so
what I'm gonna do actually is I'm gonna
we need to continually train the model
every time we run the program which I
know seems like a pain but unless we
want to save the model which I guess I
could actually show in this video later
as well we just have to train it and
then we can use it directly after so
after we've you know tested this we
don't need to do this evaluate any more
we are trained the model we can use it
to use it we actually just need to use a
method called predict but I'm gonna talk
about kind of how this works because it
is a little finicky
we're not even just finicky but just not
intuitive so essentially when you want
to make a prediction using the model I'm
gonna set up just a variable prediction
here you simply use model dot predict
and then you pass it a list now what you
would think you would do is just pass it
like the input right so in this case we
just pass it some input that's in the
form twenty eight twenty eight and it
would predict but that's not actually
how it works and when you want to make a
prediction what you need to do is put
whatever your input shape is inside of a
list or actually well you can do it
inside of the list but you can also do
it inside an NP array as well like an
umpire right and the
to do that is because what predict does
is it gives you a group of predictions
so it's expecting you to pass in a bunch
of different things and it predicts all
of them using the model so for example
if I want to do the predictions on all
of my test images to see what they are I
can do prediction equals multi-purpose
images and if I print out like
prediction you guys will see what this
looks like so let's run this here and
see what we get so obviously we have to
train them all each time which is a
little bit annoying but we can save it
later on and obviously this one runs
pretty quickly so it's not a huge deal
all right so there we go so now you can
see this is actually what our
predictions look like now this is a
really weird kind of like looking
prediction thing I mean we're getting a
bunch of different lists now that's
because right our output layer is ten
neurons so we're actually getting an
output of ten different values and these
different values are representing how
much the model thinks that each picture
is a certain class right so you can see
we're getting like 2.6 to the e to the
negative 0-6 which means that obviously
a very small number so it doesn't think
whatsoever that it's that and then I'm
trying to find if we can see ones that
aren't like to the e but apparently it's
we didn't really get lucky enough with
it showing because it just cuts some of
them off here but if I print out let's
say like prediction zero and I guess
we're gonna have to run this again I
probably should have thought of that
then you guys will see exactly what the
prediction list looks like and I'm gonna
show you how we can actually interpret
this to determine what class it is
because this means nothing to us we want
to know is it a sandal is it a shoe is
it a shirt like what is it right so
there you go so this is what the list
looks like so if we look through the
list here we can see these are all the
different probabilities that are our
network is predicting so what we're
actually gonna do essentially is we're
gonna take whatever the highest number
is there we're gonna say that is the
predicted value so to do that what we do
is we say n P dot Arg max okay and we
just put it around this list now what
this does is it just gets the largest
value and finds like the index of that
so in this case since we have ten
neurons the first one is representing
obviously
T
the last photos representing ankle boot
it'll find whatever neuron is the
largest value and give us the index of
that neuron so if it's like the third
neuron then it's gonna give us pull over
right and and that's how that works so
if we want to see the actual like name
though rather than just the index then
what we need to do is just take this
value and pass it into class names so
let's say class underscore names and
then we'll index whatever the value is
that this NPR max prediction zero gives
us right so let's run this and see what
we get now all right so there we go so
we can see that now we're actually
getting ankle boot as our prediction
which makes a lot more sense for us
right rather than just giving us like
that prediction array or whatever it was
okay so that's great but the thing is
how do we calculate validate this is
actually working well what we need to do
now or not what we need to do but what
we should do now is show the input and
then show what the predicted value is
and that way we as the humans which know
obviously which is which can validate
that so what I'm gonna do actually just
set up a very basic for loop and what
this for loop is gonna do is loop
through a few different images in our
test images and show them on the screen
and then also show the prediction so
show what they actually are and then
show the prediction as well so to do
this I'm just gonna say for I guess in
this case I in range five and what we'll
do is I'm gonna say PLT dot grid I'm
just gonna set up a very basic like plot
to show the image I'm gonna aim it show
our test underscore images I right I'm
gonna do the see map thing so I say see
map equals in this case PLT dot cm dot
binary which is just gonna give us like
the grayscale and then I'm gonna say P
ot dot X label which just means
underneath and I'm gonna say is equal to
actual and in this case I'm gonna say
plus and what do we want to do we need
to get the actual label of our test
image which would be in test underscore
labels I and then what I'm gonna do is
add a header and say this is what the
model predicted so to do this I'm gonna
say PLT dot I believe it's sorry not
header it's about title and the title
will simply be
prediction plus in this case we're gonna
say prediction and then I now the reason
we can do this we're sorry we're gonna
have to literally copy this this whole
argument and we'll put that here except
instead of zero we're gonna put I and
just that way it will show all of the
different image just right so now what
I'm going to do is for each loop here
I'm gonna peel T dot show which means
I'm gonna show those images so we can
see exactly what they look like so quick
recap in case I kind of skimmed over
some stuff all we're doing is setting up
a way to see the image as well as what
it actually is versus what the model
predicted so we as the humans can kind
of validate this is actually working and
we see okay this is what the image and
the input is and this is what the output
was from the model so let's run this and
wait for it to train I'll fast forward
through this and then we will show the
images okay so a quick fix here I just
ran this and I got an air I mean to do
class names and then test labels I and
that's obviously because the test labels
are gonna have like the index of all
these so I can't just put like the
number value have to put the class names
so that we get the correct thing anyways
I hope that makes sense to you guys
let's run this now you can see that was
the air I ran into again fast forward
and then I would back alright so I am
back now this is a little bit butchered
and how I'm actually showing it but you
can see that it's saying the prediction
for this was the ankle boot and it
actually is an ankle boot now if I close
this it'll just show four more because
that's the way I've set it up so now you
can see that prediction pullover it
actually was a pullover all right we see
we get prediction trouser it actually
was a trouser and prediction trouser
actual trouser prediction shirt actual
shirt and obviously if you want to see
more you could keep looping through all
of these and doing that now say you just
want to predict on one image well what
you could do for example is alright and
this is kind of a weird way what I'm
about to do but you'll see let's say we
wanted to just predict like what the
seventh image was well then what I would
do is just say test images 7 which is
gonna give us that 28 by 28 array and
then I would just put it inside of a
list so that that way it gets it's given
the way that it's supposed to look
but that also means that our prediction
list right we're gonna get is equal to
this it's gonna look like prediction and
then it's gonna have this and then
inside it's gonna have all those
different values so it's gonna have like
0.001 0.9 but it's gonna be a list
inside of a list so that's just
something to keep in mind when you're
working with these predictions because
that is really the only way to do it and
that this is exactly what tensorflow
recommends on their website as well if
you're just predicting for one item just
put it inside of a list so that it's
gonna work fine so anyways that has kind
of been it on using the model to predict
stuff and future videos we'll get into a
little bit more advanced stuff this was
a very easy classification problem just
really meant to give you an introduction
and personally I think if you never
worked with any machine learning stuff
this is pretty cool that in a few
minutes of just kind of writing a little
bit of code whether you understand it or
not you can create a simple model that
can classify fashion items like a shirt
and a t-shirt and I don't know that's
pretty cool to me and in future videos
obviously we're gonna be doing a lot
cooler stuff it's gonna be a little bit
more advanced but hopefully you guys can
stick with it I'd love to know what you
guys think of this series so far so
please leave a comment down below it
helps me to kind of tweak my lessons and
all that as we go forward if you guys
enjoyed the video please leave a like
and subscribe and I will see you again
[Music]
now in today's video what we're gonna be
doing is talking about text
classification with tensorflow 2.0 now
what I'm gonna be doing just to be full
fully transparent with you guys here is
following along with the actual official
tutorials on the tensorflow 2.0 tutorial
now I find that these are actually the
best in terms of like kind of a
structure to start with to understand
very basic neural networks for some
pretty simple tasks I would say and then
we're gonna stray away from those we're
gonna start using our own data our own
networks our own architecture and we'll
start talking about kind of some of the
issues you have when you actually start
applying these to real data so so far
you guys have noticed and I've seen some
comments on already that the data is
really easy to load in and even
pre-processing it like in the last one
we just divided everything by 255 like
that's really simple in the real world
your data is definitely not that nice
and there's a lot of stuff that you need
to play with and modify to make it
actually usable so anyways we'll follow
along this one for today and essentially
the way that it works is we're gonna
have movie reviews and we're just gonna
classify them use their as either
positive or negative now what we'll do
is we'll just look at some of the movie
reviews and then we'll talk about the
data we'll talk about the architecture
using stuff to predict some issues might
run into and all of that now I don't
know how many video parts this is gonna
be I'm gonna try to record it all at
once and just split it up based on how
long it takes but with that being said
enough talking let's get started so what
we're gonna do obviously is start in our
file here and again this is gonna be
really nice because we can just steal
kind of the data from cara's what we'll
start by doing is just importing
tensorflow as TF we're gonna say from
tensorflow import Chara's and then we're
going to say import numpy as NP now
before I start I ran into a quick issue
when I was actually trying to do this
just following along with the official
tutorial and that was that the data that
I want to grab here actually doesn't
work with the current version at numpy
that comes with tensorflow
it's on their github as an issue but
anyways to fix this what we need to do
is install the previous version of numpy
so to do this what I'm actually gonna do
is just say pip
like pip numpy version or something
because I want to see what version it is
incorrectly pip version number I want to
find what version it is and then just go
down to that version okay so I found the
version of numpy what we're gonna do now
is actually just install the correct
version an UMP ID to make it work for
this tutorial now this should be fine
for everything going forward and if you
want to install the most recent version
of numpy after doing this go feel free
but to do this all I'm gonna do is just
say pip install and then numpy equals in
this case one point one six point one I
believe the version we're using right
now is 0.3 at least at the time of
recording this but just change it to
this version and hopefully in the future
they'll fix that issue so that we don't
have to do this but anyways I'm going to
install that yeah you're gonna have to
add two equal signs and I already have
this installed so that should just not
do anything but you guys just make sure
you do that I'll leave the command in
the description now after we do that
what I'm gonna do is just load in the
data go say data equals in this case
care as dot data sets dot I am what is
it
I am DB now I believe this stands for
like some something movie database I
don't really know but anyways that's
what the database is and we're gonna do
the same thing we did in the previous
tutorial which is just split this into
training and testing data so to do that
I'm gonna say train underscore data
train underscore labels comma and then
in this case we'll say test underscore
at data and then test underscore labels
equals in this case data load underscore
data now we're just gonna add one thing
in here which is num underscore words
equals in this case 10,000 now the
reason I'm doing this is because this
data set contains like a ton of
different words and what we're gonna
actually do by saying num words equals
10,000 is only take the words that are
the 10,000 most frequent which means
we're gonna leave out words that usually
are only occurring like once or twice do
it the entire data set because we don't
want to throw those into our model and
have things like be more difficult than
they have to be and just have data
that's kind of irrelevant because we're
gonna be comparing obviously movie
reviews and there's some words that are
only in like one review we should
probably just omit them because there's
nothing to really compare them to in
other data sets anyways I hope that kind
of makes them
but that's not super important there's
gonna be numbers equals 10,000 it's also
shrinks our data a little bit which
makes it a bit nicer now what we're
gonna do next is we're actually gonna
show how we can display this data now if
I start by actually just showing you
like the Train underscore data and let's
pick like the zero with one so I guess
the first one and I print this out to
the screen so I'll just go if I could
get 2pi 'the python and i guess in this
case we'll have to do i probably should
just type this to start tutorial two
when this actually prints out probably
going to take a second here just to
download the data set you can see that
what we have is actually just a bunch of
numbers now this doesn't really look
like a movie review to me does it well
what this actually is is integer encoded
words so essentially each of these
integers point to a certain word and
what we've done just to make it wait
easier for our model to actually
classify these and work with these is
we've given each word one integer so in
this case maybe like the word the
integer one stands or something the
integer 14 stands for something and all
we've done is just added those integers
into a list that represents where these
words are located in the movie review
now this is nice for the computer but
it's not very nice for us if we actually
want to read these words so we have to
do is find the mappings for these words
and then find some way to actually
display this so that you know we can
have a look at it now I'll be honest
here I'm just gonna take this from what
they have on the tensorflow website on
how to do this typically you would
create your own mappings for words with
your own dictionary and you just already
have that information but fortunately
for us tensorflow already does that so
to do that I'm gonna say word underscore
index equals in this case I am vb.net
underscore word underscore index like
this now what this does it's actually
going to give us a dictionary that has
those keys and those mappings so that
what we can do is well figure out what
you know what these integers actually
mean so when we want to print it out
later we can have a look at them so I'm
gonna say now is word underscore index
equals in this case K : and then we're
gonna say what do you call it the plus
three for K the
in word underscore index dot items so I
might have been incorrect here this
doesn't actually give us a dictionary
this just gives us like tuples that have
the string and the word in them I
believe and then what we're doing here
is we're gonna say instead of C sorry
this should be B my apologies is we're
gonna get word just break that tupple up
into K and V which stands for key and
value and the key will be the word the
value will be obviously the integer yes
that's what it will be and we're gonna
say for word items and index we'll break
that up and then we're just gonna add a
bunch of different keys into our data
set now the reason we're gonna start at
plus three is because we're gonna have
actually one key or three keys that are
gonna be like special characters for our
word mapping and you guys will see how
those work in a second so I'm gonna
start by just saying word index and in
this case I'm gonna put in here pad
we're gonna talk about this in a second
so don't worry if you guys are kind of
like what are you doing right now
I'm gonna say word index and in this
case starts equals one let's say a word
underscore index and in this case I
believe it's like UNK yeah that's
correct when I say UNK equals two
now UNK just stands for unknown and I'm
gonna explain all this in a second but
it's easier just to type it out first
and we're gonna say word index in this
case inside this tag
I'm used we're going to say equals three
so what I'm doing essentially is all of
the words in our training and testing
data set have like keys and values
associated with them starting at one so
what I'm doing is I'm just gonna add
three to all of those values so that
what I can actually do is assign my own
kind of values that are gonna stand for
padding start unknown and unused so that
if we get values that are not valid we
can just assign them to this essentially
in the dictionary now what I'm gonna use
for padding you guys will see in just a
second essentially it's just so we can
make our all our movie sets the same
length so we'll add this what's known as
pad tag and we'll do that by adding 0
into our actual movie review list so
that we're gonna make each movie review
the same length and the way we do that
essentially is if they're not the same
length so maybe one's a hundred maybe
ones 200 we want all them to be 200 the
100 length
list will for what we'll do is we'll
just add a bunch of padding to the end
of it to make it length 200 and then
obviously our model will hopefully be
able to differentiate the fact that that
is padding and then we don't care about
the padding and that we shouldn't even
bother they're really like looking at
that right alright so now what I'm gonna
do is add this kind of complicated line
here just to I don't even know why they
have this to be quite honest this is the
way the tensor flows has decided to do
they're like word mappings but
apparently you need to add this reverse
underscore underscore word underscore
index which is equal to dictionary and
then in here we're gonna say value comma
key for key comma value in word
underscore index I believe that's
correct and what this is gonna do
actually sorry not word index word index
dot items what this is gonna do is okay
I understand now now that I've typed it
out you just swap all the values in the
keys so that right now we actually have
a dictionary that has all of the like
the keys first which is gonna be the
word and then the values where we
actually want it the other way around so
we have like the integer pointing to the
word because we're gonna have our data
set that is gonna contain just integers
like we've seen here and we want these
integers to be able to point to a word
as opposed to the other way around so
what we're doing is just reversing this
with a reverse word index list just our
dictionary sorry essentially that's what
this is doing here
all right now that we've done that the
last step is just to add a function and
what this function will do is actually
decode essentially all of this training
and testing data into human readable
words so there's different ways to do
this again I'm just gonna take this
right from the tensorflow website
because this part's not super important
and I'd rather just you know do it
quickly than spend too much time on it
so if we're just gonna say return blank
string dot join and in this case we're
gonna say reverse word index dog gets in
this case we're gonna say I comma
question mark now what this does
essentially if you don't know how the
gap works is we're gonna try
to get index I which we're gonna define
in a second if we can't find a value for
that then what we'll do is just put
question mark and so which is a default
value which means we won't crash we're
having like a key error in our
dictionary and we're gonna say for in
this case I in text I don't know why
where I have text typed I think I might
have messed something up here so one
second here ootek sir is the parameter
my apologies
so anyways that's what this gonna do is
just going to return to us essentially
all of the the keys that we want or the
human readable words my apologies so now
what we'll do is what simply just print
out D code review and I'm just gonna
give it some test status let's say test
for example zero and I guess we're gonna
have to test underscore data it doesn't
really matter if you train or test data
but let's just have a look at test out
of zero and see what that actually looks
like let's run that assuming I make any
mistakes we should actually get some
valid output in just a second this
usually takes a minute to run up I am DB
is not defined what did I type here I
typed that as data my apologies so where
we say IMDB which is right here we just
need to replace that with data in my
other file I called it IMDB so that's
why I made a mistake there but let's run
that again and hopefully now we will get
some better looking output so let's wait
for this and see dict object has no
attribute items this needs to be items
classic typos by Jim one more time third
time is a charm hopefully let's see and
there we go so now we can see that we're
actually getting all of this decoded
into well this text now I'll allow you
guys to read through it but you can see
that we have these kind of keys that
we've added so start which is one which
will automatically be added at the
beginning of all of our text and then we
have these un Ches which stand for
unknown character essentially and then
we don't have any other keys in here but
say for example we had like some padding
we had added to this we would see those
Pat tags as well in here it's not
essentially how that works if you'd like
to look at some other reviews just mess
around with kind of the values and the
index here throw them into deep code
review and then we can actually see what
they look like
now something to note quickly is that
our review
our different lengths now I've talked
about this already but let's just
compare two reviews to really test that
I'm not just making this up so I'm gonna
say test underscore data why I have a
capital here test underscore down to
zero so the length of test under core
data is zero and the length of let's try
test underscore data one just to prove
to you guys that these are actually
different lengths which means there's
something kind of fancy we're gonna have
to do with that padding tag which I was
talking about there so let's go into
text class classification
let's go CMD and then Python in this
case tutorial to PI now I guess we're
gonna get that output again which is
probably what's causing this to just
take a second to run you can see that we
have length 68 and we have length to 60
now this is not gonna work for our model
and the reason this doesn't work is
because we need to know what our inputs
shut shape sorry and size is gonna be
just like I talked about before we
define the input nodes or the input
neurons and the output neurons so we
have to determine how many input neurons
there's going to be and how many output
neurons there's gonna be now if we're
like we don't know how large our data is
gonna be and it's different for each
woody call it's entry then that's an
issue so we need to do something to fix
that so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna use this padding tag to
essentially set a definite length for
all of our data now we could go ahead
and pick the longest review and say that
will make all of the reviews that length
but what I'm gonna do is just pick an
arbitrary number in this case we'll just
do like 250 and say that that's the
maximum amount of words we're gonna
allow in one review which means that if
you have more than 250 words in your
review we're just gonna get rid of all
those and if you don't have 256 words or
250 words or whatever it is we're just
gonna add these padding tags to the end
of it until eventually we reach that
value so the way to do this is again
using those fancy tensorflow functions
now if you don't like these functions
and like what these do for you and how
they just kind of save you some time go
ahead and try to write them yourself and
if you want help on how to do that feel
free to reach out to me on dis corridor
in the comments or whatever but I
personally just use them because it
saves me a quite quite a bit of time in
terms of like typing out
functions and I already know how to do a
lot of what these functions do so for me
it doesn't really make sense to just
retype them out when I can just use
these kind of fancy tools so what we're
going to say is we're gonna redefine our
training and testing data and what we're
gonna do is just trim that data so that
it's only at or kind of normalized that
data so it's at 250 words so to do that
I'm gonna say train underscore data
equals in this case Kara's got
pre-processing no idea if that's how you
spell it we'll have to check that in a
second dot sequence dot pad underscore
sequence so pre-processing I think
that's correct I guess we'll see and
then in here we have to define a few
different parameters so what we'll first
do is we'll give that train underscore
data we're gonna say value equals which
will be the pad value so what we add to
the end of in this case our numpy array
to pad it per se and in this case we'll
just use this pad tag so we'll say
literally word index pad so let's copy
that and put that there we're gonna say
our padding equals in this case post we
just means we're gonna Pat after as
opposed to before we also could pad
before but that doesn't really make too
much sense for this and then what we'll
say is max in this case Len equals and
then you pick your number that you want
to make all of the values equal to now
tensorflow did like 256 I'm just gonna
do 250 and see if this makes a
difference in terms of our accuracy for
the model and I'm literally just gonna
copy this and change these values now to
test underscore data instead of Train
underscore data and this will do the
same thing on our other data set oops
didn't mean to do that so test
underscore date/time like that so quick
recap here because we are at 17 minutes
now essentially what we've done is we've
loaded in our data we've looked at our
data we've created the word mappings
essentially for our data so that we can
actually figure out what at least
integers mean we've created a little
function here that will decode the
mappings for us so we just pass it a
word review that's integer encoded it
decodes it and then if we can print that
information out to the screen to have a
look at it what we've just done now is
we've done what's called
reprocessing our data which means just
making it into a form that our model can
actually accept and that's consistent
and that's what you're always gonna want
to do with any data that you have
typically it's gonna take you a bit more
work than what we have because it's only
two lines to pre-process our data
because Cara's kind of does it for us
but for the purpose of this example
that's fine
all right so now that we've done that
it's actually time to define our model
now I'll show you quickly just to make
sure you know you guys believe me here
that this is working in terms of
pre-processing pre-processing our data
so it's actually gonna make things the
same length so we'll say train
underscore data test underscore data
let me just print this out to the screen
so python tutorial 2 again we're gonna
get these integer mappings but we'll get
the length at the end as well and
another error of course we need to add
an S to these sequences again my
apologies guys on that classic typos
here so anyways I had pre process
processing sequence we need sequences
and now if I run this you can see that
we have a length of 250 and 250 so we've
kept that consistent now for some oh I'm
printing I don't know why this is
printing toot oh it's because I'm
printing it here and then I'm printing
it here but you guys get the idea in
that we've now made them actually the
same size so let me remove these print
statements all of them so we can stop
printing trained out of 0 up here as
well and now let's start defining our
model
so I'll just say model down here is a
little comment just to help us out so
what I'm gonna do now is similar to what
I've done before except in the last one
you might have noticed that the way I
define my model was okay I'll show you
in a second once I've finished typing
this so we did Kara's dot sequential and
then what we actually did was just had a
list in here that had all the layers
that's fine you can do that but in this
case we're gonna have a few more layers
so what we're gonna do actually is add
these layers just by doing the model dot
add it's precisely the same thing as
before except instead of adding them in
this list we're just gonna do it using
this method so now we're going to say
Kara's dog layers dot in this case and
bedding and I'll talk about what these
layers do in a second we're gonna 10016
and then we're just gonna actually copy
this four times and just change these
layers and the
parameters as well so now we're gonna
say global average pooling 1d and then
do that and then we're gonna add a dense
layer here and another dense layer and
change these parameters so we'll say
dense and we'll say in this case 16 will
say activation equals Lilu are rectified
linear unit whatever you guys want to
call it and then we'll do down here 1
and activation equals rectified linear
unit as well actually sorry not really
really we're gonna do Sigma my apologies
so now we'll actually talk about the
architecture of this model and how I
came up with picking these layers and
well what these layers are well what we
want essentially is we want the final
output to be whether the review is good
or whether the review is bad I think I
mentioned that at the beginning of the
video so what we're actually gonna do is
just have either that like what one
output neuron and that neuron should be
either 0 or 1 we're somewhere in between
there to give us kind of a probability
of like we think it's like 20% 1 80% 0
something along those lines now we can
accomplish that by using sigmoid because
what it will do again we've talked with
the sigmoid function is it'll squish
everything so whatever our value is in
between 0 & 1 which will give us a nice
way to test if our models actually
working properly and to get it the value
that we want
hey guys so now it's time to talk about
word embeddings and this embedding layer
and then what the global average pooling
one D layer is doing now we already have
an idea of what these dense layers are
with these activation functions like
real uu and sigmoid but what we're
actually gonna do today or I guess just
in this video is talking about the
architecture of this network kind of how
it works on a high-level understanding
and then in the next video we'll do is
actually get into training and using the
network so what I'm gonna do first is
just start by talking about these first
two layers and specifically what this
embedding layer is because it's very
important and then we will draw the
whole network or the whole I guess
network is right we're way to put it the
whole architecture and talk about how it
fits together and what it's actually
doing so let's get started now the
easiest way to kind of explain this is
to use an example of two very similar
sentences so I'm just gonna say the
first sentence is have a great day and
the next sentence will be have a good
day now I know my handwriting is
horrible so just give me a break on that
it's also hard to kind of write with
this tablet so that's my excuse but
anyways these two sentences looking at
them as human beings we can tell pretty
quickly that they're very similar now
yes great and good maybe one has more
emphasis on having an amazing day
whatever it is but they're very similar
and they pretty well have the same
meaning right maybe we know when we
would use the sentence in kind of the
context in which like these words great
and good are used and day and day and
all this right it just we understand
what they are now the computer doesn't
have that same understanding at least
right off the bat when looking at these
two sentences now in our case we've
actually integer encoded all of our
different values so what we end up
having are all of our different words
sorry is our sentences end up looking
something like this so we're gonna have
this first word will represent a zero a
will be one great will be two and day
will be 3 so then down here we'll have 0
1 in this case we're gonna say good is 4
and day is 3 as well so this means if we
integer encode these sentences we have
some lists that look something like this
now this one clearly is the first
sentence and this one down here will
the second sentence now if we just look
at this and we pretend that you know we
don't even know what these words
actually are all we can really tell is
the fact that two is different from four
now notice what I just said there two is
different from four when in reality if
we look at these two words we know that
they're pretty similar yes they're
different words yes they're different
lengths whatever it is but we know that
they have a similar meaning and the
context in which they're used in this
sentence is the same now our computer
obviously doesn't know that because all
it gets to see is this so what we want
to do is try to get it to have an
understanding of words that have similar
meanings and to kind of group those
together in a similar form or in a
similar way because obviously in our
application here of classifying movie
reviews the types of words that are used
in the context in which they are used
really makes a massive difference to
trying to classify that as either a
positive or a negative review and if we
look at great and good and we say that
these are two completely different words
well that's gonna be a bit of an issue
when we're trying to do some
classifications so this is where our
embedding layer comes in now again just
to say here one more time like we know
these are different but we also would
know for example say if we replace this
four with a three well all our computer
again would know is that two is
different from three just like four is
different from two it doesn't know how
different they are and that's what I'm
trying to get at here is our embedding
layer is going to try to group words in
a similar kind of way so that we know
which ones are similar to each other so
let me now talk about specifically the
embedding layer so let me just draw a
little grid here now what our embedding
layer actually does kind of like I don't
want to say the formal definition but
the more mathy definition is it finds
word vectors for each word that we pass
it or generates word vectors and uses
those word vectors to pass to the future
layers now a word vector can be in any
kind of dimensional space now in this
case we've picked 16 dimensions for each
word vector which means that we're gonna
have vectors maybe something like this
and a vector again it's just a straight
line with a bunch of different
coefficients in some kind of space that
is
in this case 16 dimensions so let's
pretend that this is a 16 dimensional
vector and this is the word vector for
the word half now in our computer it
wouldn't actually be have it would be
zero because again we have integer
encoded stuff but you kind of you get
the point so we'll say this is the word
vector for half now what we're gonna do
immediately when we create this
embedding layer is let me actually get
out of this quickly for one second is we
initially create 10,000 word factors for
every single word and in this case every
single number that represents a word so
what we're gonna do is when we start
creating this embedding layer we see
that we've have an embedding layer is
we're gonna draw 10,000 word vectors and
just kind of some random way that are
just there and each one represents one
word and what happens when we call the
embedding layer is it's gonna grab all
of those word vectors for whatever input
we have and use that as the data that we
pass on to the next layer now how do we
create these word vectors and how do we
group words well this is where it gets
into a bit complicated math I'm not
really gonna go through any equations or
anything like that but I'll kind of give
you an idea of how we do it now we want
to so let me get rid of this word have
because this is not the best word vector
example and let's say that this word
vector is great
now upon creating our word vector our
embedding layer we have two vectors we
have great and we have good and we can
see that these vectors are kind of far
apart from each other and we determine
that by looking at the angle between
them and we say that this angle maybe
it's like I don't know 70 degrees or
something like that and we can kind of
determine that great and good are not
that close to each other but in reality
we want them to be pretty close to each
other we want the computer to look at
great and good and be like these are
similar words let's treat them similarly
in our neural network so what we want to
do hopefully is have these words and
these vectors kind of move closer
together whether it's good going all the
way to great or great going all the way
to good or vice versa right we just want
them to get close together and kind of
be in some form of a group so what we do
is we try to look at the context in
which these words are used rather than
just the content of the words which
would just be what this
looks like we want to figure out how
they how they're used so we'll look at
the words around it and determine that
you know when we have a and day and a
and day maybe that means that these are
like related in some way and then we'll
try to group these words now it's way
more complicated than that don't get me
wrong but it's kind of like a very basic
way of how they group together is we
look at the words that surround it and
just different properties of the
sentence involving that word and then we
can kind of get an idea of where these
words go and which ones are close to
each other so maybe after we've done
some training what happens is our word
embeddings are what is known as learned
just like we're learning and teaching
our neural network and we get we end up
getting great and good very close
together and these are what their word
vector representations are we can tell
that they're close again by looking at
the angle in between here maybe it's
like 0.2 degrees and what that means is
these two vectors which are just a bunch
of numbers essentially are very close
together so when we feed them into our
neural network they should hopefully
give us a similar output at least for
that specific neuron that we give it to
now I know this might be a little bit
confusing but I'm gonna go we're gonna
talk about this a bit more with another
drawing of the whole network but I hope
you're getting the idea the whole point
is embedding layer is to make word
vectors that and then group those word
vectors or kind of like make them close
together based on words that are similar
and that are different so again just
like we would have grading good here we
would hope that a word vector like bad
would be down here where it has a big
difference from great and good so that
we can tell that these words are not
related whatsoever all right so that's
how the embedding layer works now what
ends up happening when we have this
embedding layer is we get an output
dimension of what's known as 16
dimensions and that's just how many
coefficients essentially we have for our
vector so just like if you have a 2d
line so like if this our grid in 2d and
we say that this is X and this is y we
can represent any line by just having
like some values like ax plus B y equals
C now this is the exact same thing that
we can do in in n dimensions which means
like any amount of dimensions so for a
16 dimensional line I'm not gonna draw
them all but we would start with
like ax plus B y plus cz plus DW and so
on and we would just have again 16 of
these coefficients and then some kind of
constant value
maybe we call it lambda that is like
what it's what it equals to what the
equation equals to and that's how we
define a line I'm pretty sure I'm doing
this correctly in in n dimensions so
anyways once we create that line what we
actually want to do is we want to scale
the dimension down a little bit now
that's just because 16 dimensions is a
lot of data especially when we have like
a ton of different words coming into our
network we want to scale it down to make
it a little bit easier to actually
compute and to train our network so
that's where this global average pooling
1d layer comes in now I'm not gonna talk
about this in two depth in too much
depth but essentially the way to think
of the global average pooling 1d is that
it just takes whatever dimension our
data is in and just puts it in a lower
dimension now there's a specific way
that it does that but again I'm not
gonna talk about that it's not super
important if you care about that a lot
just look it up and it's not like crazy
hard but I just I don't feel the need to
go into it in this video so anyways
let's now start drawing what our network
actually looks like after understanding
how this embedding layer works so we're
gonna initially feed in a sequence and
we'll just say that this is like our
sequence of encoded words okay so say
this is our input and maybe it's
something like zero seven nine like a
thousand two hundred a thousand twenty
we have like nine again maybe we have
eight just a bunch of different
essentially numbers right so we're gonna
pass this into our embedding layer and
all this is gonna do is it's gonna find
the representation of these words in our
embedding layer so maybe are embedding
layer well it's gonna have the same
amount of words in our vocabulary so to
look up say zero it'll say maybe zero
means zero is vector is like 0.2 0.3 and
it goes to 16 dimensions but I'm just
gonna do like 2 for this example here
maybe 7 its vector is like 7 and 9.0 and
it just keeps going like this and it
looks up all these vectors so it takes
our input data and it just turns them
into a bunch of vectors and just spits
those out into our next layer now our
next layer what this does is it just
takes these vectors and just averages
them out and it just means it kind of
shrinks them they're down it down so
we'll do like a little smaller thing
here and we'll just say like average ok
so it called this one embedding and that
one is average
now this average layer now is where we
go into the actual neural network well
obviously this is a neural network but
we go into the dense layers which will
actively perform our classification so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna start
with 16 neurons and this is just again
an arbitrary number that we picked for
our network you can mess around with
different values for this and I
encourage you to do that but 16 is what
tensorflow decided to use and what I'm
just following along with so we're gonna
have 16 neurons and we're gonna pass all
of our now 16 dimensional data or
whatever dimensional data it is into
these neurons like this now this is
where we start I'm doing the dense layer
so we have this dense layer and this is
connected to one output neuron like this
so what we end up having is this
embedding layer which is gonna have all
these word vectors that represent
different words we average them out we
pass them into this 16 neuron layer that
then goes into an output layer which
will spit out a value between 0 and 1
using the sigmoid function which I
believe I have to correct myself because
in other videos I said it did between
negative 1 and 1
it just takes any value we have and puts
it in between 0 & 1
like that all right
so that is kind of how our network works
so let me talk about what this dense
layer is doing just a little bit before
we move on to the next video so what
this dense layer is going to attempt to
do essentially is look for patterns of
words and try to classify them using the
same methods we talked about before into
either a positive review or a negative
review I'm going to take all these word
vectors which again are gonna be like
similarly grouped words like great good
are gonna be similar input to this dense
layer right because we've averaged them
out and embedded them in all this and
then what we're gonna do is we're gonna
try to determine based on
what words we have and what order they
come in what our text is and we hope
that this layer of 16 neurons is able to
pick up on patterns of certain words and
where they occur in the sentence and
give us a accurate classification again
it's gonna do that by tweaking and
modifying these weights and all of the
biases that are on you know all of these
different what-do-you-call-it
layers or all of these connections or
whatever they are and then it's going to
give us some output and some level of
accuracy for our network
all right so now it's time to compile
and train our model now the first thing
we have to do is just define the model
give it an optimizer give it a loss
function and then I think we have to
define the metrics as well so we're
gonna do is gonna say model equals in
this case or so not model equals model
dot compile if I spell compile correctly
and then here we're gonna say optimizer
we're gonna use the atom optimizer again
I'm not really going to talk about what
these are that much if you're interested
in the octave I'll just look them up and
then for the loss function where you're
going to use the binary underscore cross
and Trippi
now what this one essentially is is well
binary means like two options right and
our case we want to have two options for
the output neuron which is 0 or 1 so
what's actually happening here is we
have the sigmoid function which means
our numbers gonna be between 0 & 1 but
what the loss function will do is pretty
well calculate the difference between
for example say our output neuron is
like 0.2 and the actual answer was 0
well it will give us a certain function
that can calculate the loss so how much
of a difference is 0.2 is from 0 and
that's kind of how that works again I'm
not gonna talk about them too much and
they're not like I mean they are
important but nots really like memorize
per se like you kind of just mess with
different ones but in this case binary
cross-entropy works well because we have
two possible values 0 1 so rather than
using the other one that we used before
which I don't even remember what it was
called something cross-entropy we're
using binary cross-entropy
okay so now what we're gonna do is we're
actually gonna split our training data
into two sets and the first set of our
training data is gonna be called
validation data or really I guess you
can think of it as a second the word it
doesn't really matter but what we're
gonna do is just get some validation
data and what validation data is is
essentially we can check how well our
model is performing based on the tunes
and tweaks we're doing on the training
data on new data now the reason we do
that is so that we can get a more
accurate sense of how well our model is
because we're gonna be testing new data
to get the accuracy each time rather
than testing it on data that we already
seen before which again means that the
can't simply just memorize each review
and give us either a zero or one for
that it has to actually have some degree
of I don't know like thinking or
operation so that it can work on new
data so we're gonna do is gonna say X
underscore Val equals and all we're
gonna do is just grab the train data and
we're just gonna cut it to a thousand or
ten thousand entries so there's actually
twenty five thousand entries or I guess
reviews in our training data so we're
just gonna take ten thousand of it and
say we're gonna use that as validation
data now in terms of the size of
validation data it doesn't really matter
that much this is what tensorflow is
using so I'm just kind of going with
that but again mess with these numbers
and see what happens to your model
everything with our neural networks and
machine learning really is gonna come
down to very fine what's known as hyper
parameters or like hyper tuning which
means just changing individual
parameters each time until we get a
model that is well just better and more
accurate so we're gonna say that x value
is that but then we're also gonna have
to modify our X train data to be trained
under squared data and in this case
we're just gonna do the other way around
so 10,000 : now I'll just copy this and
we're just gonna replace this again with
instead of test actually oh we have to
do this with labels sorry what am I
thinking so we're just gonna train
change this to be labels and then
instead of X values gonna be Y value and
then wide train so yeah we're not
touching the test data because we're
gonna use all that test data to test our
model and then we're just gonna use the
the training stuff or the validation
data to validate the model all right so
now that we've done that it is actually
time to fit the model so I'm just gonna
say like fit model and you'll see what
I'd name this something different in a
second it's gonna be equal to model dot
fit and in this case what we're gonna do
is gonna say X underscore train Y
underscore train we're gonna say epochs
is equal to angle tell you spell it 40
and again you can mess with this number
and see what we get based on that I'm
going to say batch underscore size
equals 512 which I'll talk about in a
second and then finally we're gonna say
validation underscore data equals and in
here we're gonna say X underscore Val
why underscore Valley and I think that's
it let me just check here quickly a one
last thing that I forgot to do we're
gonna say verbose equals one verbose
equals one now I'm not gonna lie I
honestly don't know what verbose is I
probably should've looked it up before
the video but I have no idea what that
is so someone knows please let me know
but the batch size is essentially how
many what do you call it movie reviews
we're gonna do each time or how many
we're gonna load in at once because this
thing is it's kind of I mean we're
loading all of our reviews into memory
but in some cases we won't be able to do
that and we won't be able to like feed
the model all of our reviews on each
single cycle so we just set up a batch
size that's gonna define essentially how
many at once we're gonna give and I know
I'm kind of horribly explaining what a
batch sizes but we'll get into more on
batch sizes and how we can kind of do
like buffering through our data and like
going taking some from a text file and
reading into memory in later videos when
we have like hundreds of gigabytes of
data that we're gonna be working with
okay so finally we're gonna say results
equals and in this case I believe it is
model dot evaluates and then we're gonna
evaluate this obviously on our test data
so we're gonna give it test data and
test labels so test underscore data test
underscore labels like that and then
finally what I'm gonna do is just
actually print out the results so we can
see what our accuracy is so say print
results and then get that value so let
me run this quickly neural networks text
classification let's go see MD and then
python text or that's not even when
we're using a reasoning tutorial - sorry
and let's see what we get with this this
will take a second to run through the
epoch so I'll fast-forward through that
so you guys don't have to wait alright
so we just finished doing the epochs now
and essentially our accuracy was 87
percent and this first number I believe
is the loss which is 0.33 and then you
can see that actually here we get the
accuracy values and
notice that the accuracy from our last
epoch was actually greater than the
accuracy on the test data which again
shows you that sometimes you know when
you test it on new data you're gonna be
getting a less accurate model or in some
cases you might even get a more accurate
model it really just you can't strictly
go based off what you're getting on your
training data you really do need to have
some test and validation data to make
sure that the models correctly working
so that's essentially what we've done
there and yeah I mean that that's the
model we tested it's 87 percent accurate
so now let's actually have let's
interpret some of these results a little
bit better and let's show some reviews
let's do a prediction on some of the
reviews and then see like if this our
model kind of makes sense for what's
going on here so what I'm gonna do is
I'm just going to actually just copy
some output that I have here just save
us a bit of time because I am gonna wrap
up the video in a minute here but
essentially what this does it just takes
the first review from test data gets the
model to predict that because we
obviously we didn't train it on the test
data so we can do that fine we're gonna
say review and then we print out the
decoded review we're gonna print out
with the model predicted and then we're
gonna print out what the actual label of
that was so if I run this now I'll fast
forward through the kind of training
process and we will see the other all
right
so this is what essentially our review
looks like so at least the one that we
were testing it on and you can see that
we have these little start tag and says
please give this one a Miss for and then
B R stands for like brake line or go to
the next line so we could have actually
added another tag for B R if we notice
that this was used a lot in the review
but we didn't do that so you see B R
unless this is actually part of the
review but I feel like that should be
like brake line in terms of HTML anyways
and we have some unknown characters
which could be anything that we just
didn't know what it was and it says and
the rest of the cast rendered terrible
performance as the show is flat flat
flat brbr I don't know how Michael
Madison could have allowed this one on
his plate he almost seemed he what does
it seem to know this wasn't going to
work out and his performance was quite
unknown so all yeah so anyway so you can
see that this probably had like some
emojis added or something and that's why
we have all these unknowns
and then obviously we made this review
which was pretty short to be the full
length of 2:50 so we see all these pads
that did that for us and then we have a
prediction and an actual value of zero
so we did end up getting this one
correct now I think it'd be interesting
actually to write your own review and
test it on this so in the next video
what I'm gonna do is show you how we can
save the model to avoid doing like all
of this every time we want to run the
code because realistically we don't wait
like a minute or two before we can
predict a movie review every time we
just want it to happen
instantly and we definitely can do that
I just haven't showed that yet in the
series because that's kind of in like
later what you do after you have machine
learning and obviously like this this
model trained pretty quickly like we
only had about what was it like 50,000
test data set which I it seems like a
large number but it's really not
especially when you're talking about
string data so in future videos we're
gonna be training models that take like
maybe a few days to Train at least
that's the goal or maybe a few hours or
something like that so in that case
you're probably not gonna want to train
it every time before you predict some
information so that'll be useful to know
how to save that
so in today's video we're gonna be doing
is talking about saving and loading our
models and then we're going to be doing
a prediction on some data that doesn't
come from this actual data set now I
know this might seem kind of trivial we
already know how to do predictions but
trust me when I tell you this is a lot
harder than it looks because if we're
just taking in string data that means we
have to actually do the encoding all of
the pre-processing removing certain
characters making sure that that data
looks the same as the data that our
neural network is expecting which in
this case is a list of encoded numbers
right or of encoded words that is
essentially just numbers so what were
you do to start is just save our model
so let's talk about that now so up until
this point every time we've wanted to
make a prediction we've had to retrain
the model now on small models like this
that's fine you have to wait a minute
two minutes but it's not very convenient
when you have models that maybe take you
days weeks months years to Train right
so what you want to do is when you're
done training the model you want to save
it or sometimes you even want to save it
like halfway through a training process
this is known as checkpointing the model
so that you can go back and continue to
train it later now in this video we're
just gonna talk about saving the model
once it's completely finished but in
future videos when we have larger
networks we will talk about
checkpointing and how you to how to load
your or train your model in like batches
of a different size data and all that so
what I'm gonna start by doing is just
actually bumping the vocabulary size of
this model up to 88000 now the reason
I'm doing that is just because for our
next exercise which is going to be
making predictions on outside data we
want to have as many words in our model
as possible so that when it gets kind of
some weirder words that aren't that
common it knows what to do with them so
I've done a few tests and I noticed that
with the what he called with the
vocabulary size bumped up it performs a
little bit better so we're gonna do that
so what I mean is we bump the vocabulary
size and now after we train the model we
need to save it now to save the model
all we have to do is literally type the
name of our model in this case model dot
Save and then we give it a name so in
this case let's call it model dot H 5
now H 5 is just like an extension that
means I don't know it's like I honestly
don't know why they use H 5 but it's the
extension for a saved model and care as
tensorflow so we're just gonna work with
that and that's as easy as this is it
was just gonna save our model in binary
data which means we'll be able to read
it in really quickly and use the model
when we want to actually make
predictions let's go ahead and run this
now and then we're gonna have the model
saved and then from now on we won't have
to continually train the model when we
want to make predictions I'm gonna say
python tutorial 2 and I'll be right back
once this finishes finishes running all
right so the model is finished training
notice that our accuracy is slightly
lower than it was in the previous video
really kind of a negligible difference
here but anyways just notice that
because we did bump the vocabulary size
so anyways now that we've saved the
model we actually don't have to go
through this tedious process every time
we run the code of creating and training
and fitting the model and in fact we
don't actually need to save it as well
either here to load our model in now
that it's saved and you can see the file
right here with all this this big
massive binary blob here all we have to
do to load this in is just type one line
now the line is whatever the name of
your model is it doesn't matter I'm just
gonna call it model is equal to in this
case Kara's dot models dot load
underscore model and then here you just
put the name of that file so in this
case model dot h5 now what's really nice
about this as well is you can actually
train a bunch of different models and
tweak like hyper parameters of them and
only save the best one what I mean by
that is like maybe you mess with for
example the amount of neurons in the
second activation layer or something
like that or in the second hidden layer
and then you train a bunch of models you
figure out which one has the highest
accuracy and then you only save that one
that's nice as well and that's something
we could do like overnight you could run
like your script for a few hours train
about your models figure out which one
is the best only save and then use that
one so anyways we're gonna load in this
model notice that I've actually just
commented out this aspect down here
because we are not gonna use this
anymore and now what we're gonna start
doing is actually training or testing
model on some outside data so I've gone
ahead and picked a movie review for one
of my favorite movies some of you guys
can read this if you want but it's the
Lion King absolutely love that movie so
I've decided to go with this this review
was a 10 out of 10 review so a positive
review and we're going to test our model
on this one now actually did take
is off like the IMDB website or whatever
that's called but the data set that they
use is different so this is you guys
will see it why this works a little bit
differently and what we have to do with
this so this is in a text file so what
I'm gonna do is load in the text file
here in code and then get that big blob
that's string and convert it into a form
that our model can actually use so the
first step to do this obviously is to
get that string so we're going to say
with open and in this case I've called
my file test dot txt and then I'm just
gonna set the encoding because I was
running into some issues here you guys
probably don't have to do this I was
gonna say UTF - 8 which is just kind of
a standard text encoding and we're gonna
say as f now again the reason i use
width is just because that means I don't
have to close the file afterwards
better practice if you want to use that
and now I'm gonna say 4 line in F dots
read lines which essentially just means
we're gonna get each line in this case
we only have one line but if we wanted
to throw in a few more reviews in here
and do some predictions on those that
would be very easy to do by keeping this
code structure you just throw another
line in there and now I'm just gonna say
we're gonna grab this line and we're
gonna start pre processing it so that we
can actually feed it to our model now
notice that this when we read this in
all we're gonna get is a large string
but that's no good to us we actually
need to convert this into an encoded
list of numbers right and essentially we
need to say okay so of that's a word
what number represents that put that in
a list
same with all same with the same with
animation right and we keep going and
keep going pretty well for all of the
words in here and we also have to make
sure that the size of our text is only
at max 250 words because that's what we
were using when we were training the
data so it's expecting a size of that
and if you give it something larger
that's not gonna work
or it might but you're gonna get a few
errors with that so anyways the first
step here is I'm going to say n line is
equal to line dots and I'm gonna remove
a bunch of characters that I don't want
so I'm just gonna say dot replace I
think this is the best way to do it but
maybe not um and I'm gonna replace all
the commas all of the periods all of the
brackets and all of the colons
and I'll talk about more why we want to
do that in just one second so we'll do
daughter place
I guess this daughter place should
probably be outside the bracket in the
workplace with a bracket with nothing
and I know this is there probably is a
better way to do this but for our
purposes it's not really that important
and finally we will replace all our
colons with nothing as well now again
the reason I'm doing this is because
let's go here if you have a look for
example when when you split this because
we're just gonna split this data by
spaces and to get all the words what
will end up happening is we're gonna get
words like company comma we're gonna get
words like I'm trying to find something
it has a period like art dot and then a
quotation mark right and we don't want
those to be words in our list because
there's no mapping for art period
there's only a mapping for art which
means that I need to remove all of these
kind of symbols so that when we split
our data we get the correct words now
there'll be a few times where the split
doesn't work correctly but that's ok as
long as the majority of them are working
well same thing with brackets right I
can't have irons and then a closing
bracket as one of my words so I need to
get rid of that now this reminds me I
need to remove quotation marks as well
because they use quite a few of those in
there I don't know why I closed that
document so let's do that as well with
one last replace justice a daughter
place in this case we'll actually just
do backslash quotation mark and then
again with nothing now I'm adding a dot
strip here to get rid of that backslash
N and now we're gonna say dot split and
in this case we'll split out of space
now I know this is a long line but
that's all we need to do to remove
everything and now we actually need to
encode and trim our data down to 250
words so to encode our data I'm gonna
say encode equals in this case and we're
just literally will make a function
called like review under floor in code
and we'll pass in our end line now what
review and code will do is look up the
mappings for all of the words and return
to us an encoded list and then finally
what we're gonna do and we'll create
this function in just a second don't
worry it doesn't already exist is we're
actually going to use what we've done up
here with this test data train data
Chara's pre processing stuff we're just
going to apply this to in this case our
encoded data so we add those pad tags or
we trim it down to what it needs to be
so this case will say
encode equals Kara's dot pre-processing
instead of train data we'll just pass in
this case actually a list and then
encode inside it because that's what
it's expecting to get a list of list all
right so now that we've done that our
final step would be to use the model to
actually make a prediction so we're
gonna say model dot predict and then in
this case we'll pass it's simply this
encode right here which will be in the
correct form now we'll save that under
predict and then what we'll do is just
simply print out the model so we'll say
print or not the model sorry will print
the original text which will be the
review so in this case we'll print line
and then we will print out the encoded
review just we can have a look at what
that is
and then finally we will print the
prediction so what whether the model
thinks it's positive or negative so
we'll just say predict and in this case
we'll just put zero because we're only
gonna be doing like one at a time right
okay sweet so now the last thing that we
need to do is just simply write this
reviewing code function and it'll be
good to go and start actually using our
model so I'm just gonna say define
review underscore encode this is gonna
take a string we'll just call that s
lowercase s and what we're gonna do in
here is setup a new list that we're
going to append some stuff into so I'm
just gonna say like return let's just
say like it encoded equals and then I'm
gonna start this with 1 now the reason I
start one in here is because all of our
data here where it starts has a 1 so
we're gonna start with 1 because we
won't have added that in from the other
way I hope you guys understand that just
we're setting like a starting tag to be
consistent with the rest of them and now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna loop
through every single word that's in our
S here which will be passed in as Alyssa
words we'll look up the numbers
associated with those words and add them
into this encoded list we're gonna say
for word and in this case we're gonna
say word a and s now you'll say if words
in this case word underscore index and
again we're gonna use word underscore
index as opposed to reverse word index
because word in
stores all of the words corresponding to
the letters or not the letters the
numbers which means that we can
literally just throw our data into word
index and it'll give us the number
associated with each of those words so
we're gonna say if word in word index
then we'll say encoded got append and in
this case we'll simply append in this
case word index word now otherwise what
we'll do is we'll say
encoded dot append - now what will
happen is we're gonna check here if word
if the word is actually in our
vocabulary which is represented by word
index which is just a dictionary of all
the words corresponding to all the
numbers that represent those words now
if it's not what we'll do is we'll add
in that unknown tag so that the program
knows that this is an unknown word
otherwise we'll simply add the number
associated with that word now one last
thing to do is actually just do word dot
lower here just to make sure that if we
get any words that have some weird
capitalization they are still found in
our vocabulary so like words at the
beginning of a sentence and stuff like
that uh and now with that being done I
believe we're actually finished and
ready to run this code so what's nice
about this is now that we've saved the
model we don't have to train it again so
I can literally just run this and it
should happen fairly quickly
fingers crossed let's see all right must
be a list of integrals found non
iterable object so what air is that here
um
in code encoding coded code all right so
print reviewing code ah well it would be
helpful if I returned the encoded list
and that would have been our issue there
so let's round that one more time and
see what we're getting there
and there we go sweet so this is
actually the review I know it's very
really hard to read here but if you guys
want to go ahead and read it
feel free since it's on the line King
it's obviously a positive review and
then you can see this is what we've
ended up with so our review has been
translated into this which means we'd
actually trimmed quite a bit of the
review and you can see that wherever it
says - that is actually a word that we
didn't know or that wasn't in our
vocabulary for represents the that's why
there's a lot of fours and then all the
other words have their correspondence
right now fortunately for us we picked a
8,000 vocabulary which means that we can
get indexes like 20,000 whereas before
would all been under 10,000 and you can
see that our prediction here is now 96%
positive which means that obviously like
we were going between 0 where 0 is a
negative review and once a positive
review so this classified correctly as
very positive review and we could try
this on all other kinds of reviews and
see what we get but that is how you go
about kind of transforming your data
into the form that the network expects
and that's where I'm trying to get you
guys at right now is to understand that
yes it's really easy when we're doing it
with this kind of data that just comes
in like IMDB like Cara's load data but
as soon as you actually have to start
using your own data there's a quite a
bit of manipulation that you have to do
and things that you might not think
about when you're actually feeding it to
the network and in most cases you can
probably be sure that your network is
not actually the thing that's happening
incorrectly but it's the data that
you're feeding it is not in the correct
form and it can be tricky to figure out
what's wrong with that data so with that
being said that has been it for this
video I hope you guys enjoyed that's
going to wrap up the text classification
aspect to your of neural networks
hey guys so in today's video I'm gonna
be showing you how to install tensorflow
2.0 GPU version on Anna bunt 2 / Linux
machine now this should work for any
version of Linux or any Linux operating
system although the one I am gonna be
showing you on is a bun to 18 point 0.4
now you may notice that I'm actually on
a Windows machine right now and that
this is actually just in a bunch of
terminal that's open now I'm actually
just SS aged into a server that I have
that contains to 1080 graphics card so
GTX 1080s and that's how I'm gonna be
showing you how to do this now quickly
if you don't understand the difference
between the CPU and the GPU version the
CPU version is essentially just way
slower and you would only really use the
CPU version if you don't have a graphics
card in your computer that is capable of
running tensorflow 2.0 GPU so quickly
before we go forward and you guys get
frustrated with not being able to
install this make sure that you have a
graphics card that actually works for
this programmer for this module that
means you have to have a graphics card
that is a gtx 1050 TI or higher those
are the ones that are listed on
tensorflow website as compatible with
tensorflow 2.0 GPU if you want to have a
quick thing without having to go to the
website to see if yours works even as 4
gigs of video RAM and is a GTX
generation card or higher it most likely
works with tensorflow 2.0 now I don't
know about all the different cards but
you have any questions leave them below
I'll try to answer that for you but any
1060 1070 1080 or r-tx cards they have
CUDA cores on them will work for this
essentially you just need a CUDA enable
GPU so you can check if yours meets that
requirement before moving forward now to
do this I'm just gonna be following the
steps listed on the tensorflow website
now you may run into some issues while
doing this but for Ubuntu this is pretty
straightforward and I'm essentially just
gonna be copying these commands and
pasting them in my terminal now if you'd
like to just try to do this without
following along with video go ahead but
I will be kind of showing you some fixes
that I ran into while I was doing this
um so let's go ahead and get started so
actually let me just split the screen up
so we can have a look at both them at
once I'm in my Linux machine right now
you just have to get to the terminal you
notice that I don't even have a desktop
and I'm literally just gonna start
copying and pasting these commands now
the first thing that we need
to install is actually CUDA now CUDA is
what allows us to use the CUDA cores on
our GPU to actually run the code so just
go ahead and keep copying these commands
it will take a second and I actually
already have this installed on my
machine so I'm gonna go through the
steps with you guys but again if
anything is different on my machine
that's probably because it's already
installed so if you don't know how to
copy it into a window like this you just
right click on your mouse and it'll copy
if you're using a server like I am but
anyways we'll just go through all of
these and keep going now I will have all
these commands listed in my description
as well and that should show you guys
you know if the website goes down at any
point you can just copy it from there as
well
so yeah it literally just keep going all
we're doing here is adding the video
packages we're gonna make sure we have
the Nvidia drivers for our graphics card
that are correct and then we're gonna go
ahead and install tensorflow 2.0 so yep
just go through these commands there's
not really much for me to say as I copy
these in and eventually we will get
through them all alright so now we're
gonna install the Nvidia driver you can
see that's all commented out on this
tensorflow website here copy that and I
can just continue go I don't really have
any commentary for you guys here so
we'll copy this this is gonna install
obviously the development and runtime
libraries which we need and it says
minimum four gigs or approximately four
gigabytes which will mean that's how
long it how many gigabytes is getting
take up on a machine so this will take a
second and I'll fast-forward through
these stuff if it does take a while
finally we're going to install tensor RT
I don't even know what this is but
apparently it's required and then after
we're done this we should actually be
finished installing everything that we
need for tensorflow 2.0 to work again if
you guys want to go through this just go
to the website copy all of these
commands in order paste them into here
and they should work properly
now finally what we have to do is
actually install tensorflow 2.0 so we've
got all the dependence the dependencies
installed and now to install tensorflow
2.0 we're just going to say pip 3
install tensorflow and i believe we're
gonna say - GPU and then equals equals
2.0 point
I gotta find it up here
to make sure that we do it correctly
two-point 0.0 - alpha zero like that
so then we'll do that and that should
install tensorflow 2.0 for us now I
already have this installed but this
will actually take a few minutes to
install because there is quite a bit of
stuff that it needs to download on your
computer
so one of means that has been it for
installing tensorflow 2.0 on your
computer using the GPU version again
throughout the rest of the neural
network series I'm gonna be going
forward doing this on in a bunting
machine so running all of the code I'll
do the development and windows throw the
files on my server train the model train
the models excuse me and then take the
models off and use them on my Windows
machine so if you want to validate if
this is working you can really quickly
just do Python 3 in Linux and then you
can cite do import tensorflow
and doing that you shouldn't get any
errors if you don't get any errors then
you have successfully installed tends to
flow 2.0 now a few errors here because
they're still listening and stuff wasn't
working if for some reason when you
install tensorflow
and you notice that it's not using your
GPU go ahead and uninstall the CPU
version of tensorflow so just pip 3 on
on the install and then tensorflow and I
guess you'd have to just do just
tensorflow like that and that will
install the CPU version if it is
installed in your machine so anyways
that has been it for how to install
tensorflow 2.0 GPU version on a bun -
pretty straightforward just go through
copies commands if you guys have any
questions or errors please just leave
them in the comments below and I will
try my best to help you up